Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Forschergeist, dem Podcast des Stiftverbands für die deutsche Wissenschaft.
Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße alle zur 94. Ausgabe von Forschergeist.
Und ja, wie es hier so unsere Art ist, wollen wir uns wieder mit einem Thema ausführlich beschäftigen.
Und heute geht es in so einen Wissenschaftsbereich, der auch so ein bisschen was mythisches hat
und so seine ganz eigene Kultur mitbringt, heute geht es um Vulkane.
Und um Vulkanologie und um die Forschung an Vulkanen und was es damit alles so auf sich hat, das erzählt uns heute Hans Ulrich Schmincke.
Herzlich willkommen bei Forschergeist.
Guten Tag.
Herr Schmincke, ja Sie sind was man einen alten Hasen nennt, glaube ich, was dieses Feld betrifft.
Kann man so sagen, ja.
Im wahrten Sinne des Wortes, blicken auf eine sehr sehr lange eigene Geschichte mit diesem Thema zurück
und haben, glaube ich, so alles beforscht, was man beforschen kann und auch in dem Wissenschaftsfeld sehr viel bewirkt.
Referenzwerke geschrieben, alles mögliche, Preise eingesammelt, die Liste kann ich jetzt hier gar nicht komplett runterzählen, so lang ist sie.
Vulkane faszinieren die Leute irgendwie total.
Es ist irgendwie so ein Wissenschaftsfeld, was so über die Wissenschaft darüber einfach Leute irgendwie beschäftigt.
Das hat irgendwie so was besonderes, was mythisches, was unheimliches, auch was bedrohliches in gewisser Hinsicht.
Jeder kann irgendwie was damit anfangen, nicht alle wissen, damit umzugehen.
Warum sind Sie zu diesem Thema gekommen und was war so Ihr Weg in die Wissenschaft an sich?
Der Weg in die Wissenschaft war kompliziert.
Als ich dann fertig war mit der Schule, habe ich mir überlegt, was soll ich studieren?
Und habe mir drei Fächer vorgestellt, Literatur, Kunstgeschichte und Psychologie.
Und dann habe ich mir noch mal hin und her überlegt und gedacht, das kann ich eigentlich auch als Hobby machen.
Psychologie sowieso und auch weil ich gerne lese und weil ich gerne viel mit Bildern zu tun hatte und moderne Kunst.
Dann habe ich gedacht, dann mache ich was handfestes als Beruf und da ich auch mit der Natur schon in Berührung war als Schüler,
habe ich dann Geologie gewählt.
Und bin dabei geblieben, habe aber die Richtung in meinem Fach drastisch geändert.
Ich wollte schon als Schüler nach USA, weil ich war auf einem altsprachlichen Gymnasium mit Latein und Griechisch
und konnte wenig Englisch, da habe ich es nicht geschafft und dann als Student habe ich es geschafft
und bin in die USA gegangen mit dem Ziel, Paläoökologie zu studieren.
Also die Ökologie der früheren Tiere zum Beispiel im Muschelkalk den flachen Meeren und so weiter und so weiter.
Begriff Ökologie ist ja heute allgemein bekannt.
Und dann war der Professor an der Johns Hopkins University der hatte kein Glück mit Studenten,
der konnte Studenten nicht so gut behandeln und dann dachte ich, dann mache ich Sedimente.
Aber das waren nur Doktoranden an der Universität der Johns Hopkins.
Der Sedimentologie Professor der setzte seine Leute alle an die Appalachen und dann war das im Sommer immer sehr schwül
und ich mag kein schwüles Klima, habe aber noch Biochemie gehört und die Revolution mitgekriegt in der Biologie,
die Doppelhelix und habe auch Limnologie gehört, habe da gelernt, dass der Vater der Limnologie hier,
wo ich jetzt wohne, am Plöner See gearbeitet hat, der Tiedemann.
Aber dann hörte ich von einem Gebiet, einem trockenen Gebiet im Nordwesten der USA,
riesige Basaltfelder im Staate Washington, Origon und Idaho.
Und bin dann zu dem Professor gegangen und das war dann mein Thema.
Und habe dann, das war ein sehr unbekanntes und unerforschtes Gebiet
und da habe ich mich dann als einsamer Student aus Europa in den riesigen Weiten vom westlichen Washington und Origon rumgetrieben zwei Sommer.
Wenn ich in eine Tankstelle kam, musste ich ab und zu mal hin und dann merkten die Leute,
der Mensch hat einen komischen Akzent und dann haben sie mich gefragt,
you must be from Kanada und da war ich sehr stolz.
Und ich habe insgesamt leider 13 Klapperschlangen töten müssen, weil ich ganz alleine war den ganzen Sommer.
Und habe da nur im Auto oder neben dem Auto geschlafen.
Anyway, mein Doktorvater hat mich nie besucht im Gelände, das habe ich also alles alleine geschafft,
weil er nach Kalifornien ging, um da eine Graduate School aufzubauen.
Das war derzeit so, dass Los Angeles und Berkley waren überfüllt und da hat man die kleinen Campus der University of California alle aufgebaut
und das war Santa Barbara, da habe ich dann abgeschlossen, aber dann auch promoviert in Johns Hopkins in Baltimore.
Und dann dachte ich, fachlich wäre es ganz klar gewesen, dass ich in den USA bleibe,
weil die akademische Atmosphäre und der Akzent auf sehr harter Wissenschaft ganz was anderes war
als das, was ich in Deutschland erlebt hatte als Student.
Auch die menschliche Stimmung war angenehmer und man war als Doktorand akzeptiert.
In Deutschland, was ich erlebt hatte, selbst die Dozenten waren noch von den Ordinarien, den kleinen Königen nicht richtig anerkannt.
Von welchem Jahrzehnt sprechen wir gerade?
60-64.
60 bin ich hin, 64 war ich promoviert, also ich war 26 damals, also sehr früh promoviert.
Ich hatte auch erlebt in Deutschland in Freiburg die ersten beiden Jahre,
wie da Diplomanten immer noch an ihrer Diplomarbeit saßen, waren schon Anfang 30 und hatten Familien.
Habe ich gedacht, das darf es nicht sein.
Und bin dann zurück nach Deutschland, ich hatte einen deutschen Professor kennengelernt,
der hat mich in einem Forschungsprojekt angestellt und auf den Kanaren,
da bin ich dann zur Vulkanologie endgültig gekommen und bin dabei geblieben.
Er hat mir dann nach zwei Jahren angeboten, eine Feststelle zu kriegen, wenn ich die Richtung meiner Arbeit ändere,
und da habe ich ihm gesagt, nein ich möchte meine Arbeit die Vulkanologie weiter machen
und habe mich dann über Stipendien, Habilitandenstipendien da weiter zwei Jahre lang finanzieren lassen.
Und kriegte dann einen Job an der Ruhruniversität Bochum, die war ganz neu,
das Institut war ganz neu, es war damals ein großer Bedarf in Deutschland an Universitäten.
Viele viele neue Universitäten wurden gegründet und eine davon war die Ruhruniversität Bochum.
Und danach kam dann auch Dortmund und Essen und so weiter.
Und da habe ich, ich habe mich schon in Heidelberg während der letzten beiden Jahre,
also 67 bis 69 sehr stark engagiert für Reformen in der deutschen Universität.
Ein Verein hat sich gegründet für eine neue deutsche Universität, der wurde von der Volkswagen Stiftung finanziert,
aber das Ganze hat sich dann totgelaufen.
Jedenfalls als ich nach Bochum kam, sagte mir ein Kollege, ja ich bin aus Heidelberg angekündigt worden als jemand,
der wissenschaftlich in Ordnung sei, aber politisch völlig unzuverlässig.
So lief das damals.
Und ich habe dann Reformen in Bochum in der Fakultät durchsetzen können über meine Studenten,
die in der Studentenvertretung waren, weil die hatten damals relativ viel Gewicht.
Das ging da auf 68 zu und 68 war ja die große Umwälzung in der Gesellschaft hier.
Angefangen hat es schon in Berkley 64 mit Savio mit seiner berühmten Rede.
So also in Bochum waren die Reformen ja mäßig verwirklicht, weil die Professoren an den Instituten sich alle immer noch wie kleine Könige fühlten
und die jüngeren, die Dozenten und Assistenten die wurden halt so als, mussten halt gehorchen,
was bei mir natürlich nicht klappte, weil ich war nicht so, das war nicht meine Natur.
Das liegt vielleicht auch daran, weil ich selbst Flüchtling bin und mir schon früh klar war,
dass ich mir selber meinen Weg bauen muss.
Ich bin dann da weiter, war dann Privatdozent und dann Associate Professor, also wissenschaftlicher Rat und Professor.
Und habe dann durch unsere Forschungen mir auch mein eigenes Reich bilden können,
wo ich relativ viele Doktoranden hatte, und zwar sehr gute.
Und einige von den vollen Professoren haben dann die Studenten angesprochen,
ob sie nicht bei ihnen promovieren wollten, das ist also mehrfach passiert.
Und die haben gesagt, nein ich will bei dem Herrn Schmincke promovieren.
Ich habe auch meine Studenten immer geduzt, was die meisten meiner Kollegen ganz schlimm fanden,
weil sie sagten, ich muss die doch mal prüfen in einem Examen.
Das hat mich nie überzeugt, weil für mich sind Studenten junge Kollegen, die noch nicht erfahren sind.
Und nicht Leute, die man unter einer Knute ausbilden muss und in Abhängigkeit halten muss.
Stimmt das, dass Sie alle dann nur HU genannt haben?
Ja.
Für Hans Ullrich?
Ja, das ist kürzer.
Leute, die aus USA kommen, die nennen mich Hans, weil die können Ullrich nicht aussprechen.
Aber meine /unverständlich/, die nennen mich HU.
Na jedenfalls hatte ich eine Reihe von sehr guten Studenten, wir waren eine eingeschworene Truppen,
hatten dann uns auch selber Räume besorgt, wo wir uns unterbringen konnten
und ich habe mit meiner wissenschaftlichen Arbeit dann angefangen in den ersten Jahren,
auf den kanarischen Inseln zu arbeiten, insbesondere Gran Canaria, da haben wir viele Arbeiten gemacht,
später auch Diplomanden und Dokotoranden.
Und dann später auch Teneriffa und La Palma, wir haben die 1949 Eruption als erste und einzige sehr detailliert untersucht
mit einem Doktoranden und Diplomandin.
Eruption auf La Palma?
Die Eruption auf La Palma, das ist die bisher detaillierteste Arbeit über eine historische Eruption.
Und dann habe ich 1970 angefangen, in der Eifel zu arbeiten, weil das nicht so weit weg war von Bochum.
Und die vulkanologischen Fragen, es war vulkanologisches Brachland,
weil keine Leute da gearbeitet hatten, die wirklich an den Vulkanen interessiert waren.
Der Unterschied zu den früheren Zeiten vor 100 Jahren, also 1910, 1920 gab es einen sehr guten Geologen
und auch schon 1820 aus Trier, einen berühmten Gymnasiallehrer, der dann der Lehrer von Karl Marx war.
Und das ist dann Hauptgebiet geworden und dann kam 1973 die erste Energiekrise,
wo ich meine kleine Tochter noch im Kinderwagen über die Autobahn gefahren habe,
weil am Wochenende war die Autobahn geschlossen in Deutschland.
Und dann wurde in Deutschland vom Bund und in Brüssel in Europa sehr viel Schwergewicht gelegt auf alternative Energien
und dazu gehörte auch die geothermische Energie.
Und dann sind wir mehrere Jahre relativ breit finanziert worden, und zwar relativ schnell.
Das war zu Anfang sehr kompliziert mit Brüssel, weil die ganzen Verfahrensweisen,
wie man jetzt europäische Forschung finanzierte ganz neu war.
Und ich musste angeben im Institut, wie das Gehalt der Sekretäre, die gar nicht meine Sekretärinnen waren,
das war alles auch für die Uni, die wollten erst und der Professor da wo ich war sagte,
Herr Schmincke, lassen Sie das, aber das habe ich natürlich nicht gelassen.
Und ich habe dann auch harte Briefe geschrieben nach Brüssel, die dann auch wohl eingeschlagen sind,
weil durch meine frühe Kindheit und meine ganze Entwicklung war ich kein sehr angstbesetzter Mensch
und habe Autoritäre immer angesprochen, wenn es sachliche Gründe gab.
Und das ist natürlich auch etwas, was sich in der Wissenschaft dann auch niederschlägt,
wenn man Paradigmen, die über Jahre oder Jahrzehnte bestand haben, infrage stellt, weil man merkt,
das ist nicht die richtige Erklärung.
Und da gibt es mehrere Fälle in meiner Wissenschaftsgeschichte, wo ich das gemacht habe.
Wo es zu Anfang immer ein bisschen Trouble gibt, wenn viele Kollegen denken, das ist sozusagen des Teufels diese neuen Ideen,
aber irgendwann wenn sie solide sind und das habe ich auch versucht, meinen Studenten beizubringen,
alles sehr gut zu dokumentieren und sehr sauber zu arbeiten und darauf dann die Hypothesen oder gerade die Theorien aufzubauen.
Das ist also so ein Grundverhalten gewesen und ich glaube, sechs, sieben meiner Doktoranden,
oder inzwischen sind es, glaube ich, noch mehr, sind Professoren in Deutschland, in Schweden, USA.
Was haben Sie denn ursprünglich genau studiert?
Wenn es die Vulkanologie noch nicht gab, was waren dann jetzt konkret die Felder, die Sie studiert haben?
Also Vulkanologie als Studienfach gibt es eigentlich nicht, man studiert, je nachdem in welchem Richtung man gehen will.
Man kann Geophysik studieren, dann macht man die seismische Erkundung der Vulkane,
der Aufstiegswege, des Erdmantels, dann ist man mehr Geophysiker.
Man kann, was klassischerweise früher in Deutschland viel gemacht wurde, mehr Mineralogie machen und Gesteinschemie,
das sind aber dann oft Leute, die gucken sich die Vulkane gar nicht an.
Die sind interessiert an den physikochemischen Vorgängen bei der Kristallisation eines Magmas.
Was passiert bei welchen Drucken, bei welchem Sauerstoff, Partialdruck und so weiter.
Welchen Wassergehalt, welchen CO2-Gehalt bildet sich dieses Mineral und so weiter.
Was passiert, wenn ein Magma abkühlt, basaltisches Magma, das sind die normalen Magmen auf der Erde und auf dem Mond und so weiter.
Wenn die abkühlen in einer Magmakammer, dann können sich daraus ganz andere Magmen bilden.
Weil zuerst bestimmte Elemente, wie Eisen, Magnesium, Chrom, Nickel in einigen Mineralen eingebaut werden
und die sinken dann ab oder bleiben an der Seite von einer Magmakammer und dann ändert sich die Zusammensetzung der Schmelze.
Wir nennen das Fraktionierung oder Differenziation.
Und die großen explosiven Vulkane und einer, den wir intensiv bearbeitet haben, mehrere Diplomanden und Doktoranden,
ist der Laacher See Vulkan, das ist die größte Eruption in Europa, in Mitteleuropa außerhalb Italiens
in den letzten paar hunderttausend Jahren.
Die Eruption vor 11000 Jahren war größer als die des Vesuvs.
Die berühmte Pompeji-Eruption, es war also sehr große Eruption und die Asche finden wir noch in Schweden und in Dänemark und in Polen.
War ein riesen… und das war auch eine sehr schwefelreiche Eruption, das haben wir dann auch untersucht später,
die wohl auch dann das Klima eine Zeit lang beeinflusst hat.
Mich würde noch mal interessieren, welche Fächer sozusagen einen zur Vulkanologie führen können.
Also wir hatten die Geophysik,…
Mineralogie.
Mineralogie, es gibt ja auch noch die Petrologie.
Die Petrologie gehört mit der Mineralogie ein bisschen zusammen, da ist der Übergang sehr eng zu den Kristallographen,
die interessieren sich nur für die Kristalle.
Die Petrologen interessieren sich für ein größeres System, ein Magma oder ein metamorphes Gestein.
Und das ist das, was mich in Deutschland so gestört hat.
In den USA an der Johns Hopkins Universität nur Doktoranden, 20 Doktoranden und acht Professoren,
das waren also paradiesische Zustände, aber sehr harte Arbeit.
Alle Doktoranden haben von morgens 9 bis nachts um 23 Uhr gearbeitet die ganze Woche.
Viel härter als in Deutschland die Doktoranden und das ist sehr weit verbreitet dort.
Und da studiert man dann nur Geologie.
Und da sind experimentelle Leute, die produzieren künstliche Kristalle bei verschiedenen Drucken und Temperaturen,
und dort sind Leute, die gucken sich Sedimente an in den Gebirgen, Appalachengebirge oder die Paläontologen
und die heißen alle Geologist und da gibt es nicht diese Aufteilung wie bei uns.
Und das ist das, was mich so geärgert und deprimiert hat in Deutschland, diese Institute.
Wo die Professoren sich so als mini Max Planck Institute fühlen.
Das ist diese Hierarchie, die sich ja auch in den Titeln ausdrückt.
Herr Professor Doktor, das ist etwas, was mir immer sehr komisch vorkam.
Nicht Ihr Ding, ja, kann ich verstehen.
Und darum habe ich es auch nie benutzt.
Und diese Aufteilung hat dazu geführt, dass viele Teile der deutschen Wissenschaft international nicht mehr so anerkannt waren.
Und dann, ich kann mich erinnern, 64, als ich fertig war, hat ein Physiker Moosbacher, glaube ich, oder so ähnlich,
der hat am Caltech, California Institute of Technologie 64, ich weiß nicht, ob er da promoviert hat
oder als Postdoc da war, und als der dann …
oder hat den Nobelpreis gekriegt, ja, der hat den Nobelpreis gekriegt, stimmt.
Da war er, glaube ich, noch in Passadena am California Institute of Technology,
und dann hat man in München gesagt, den Mann müssen wir uns holen.
Und dann hat er gesagt, ich komme nur, wenn ihr ein Departement macht.
Wenn ihr also von dieser Einzelstruktur der Institute weggeht und dein Departement macht.
Und das habe ich mir lange gewünscht in den Erdwissenschaften.
In Bochum war es nicht möglich und in Kiel das war nun ein Forschungsinstitut, wo ich 1990 berufen wurde,
das war keine Universität, das war hauptsächlich Forschung und das war ein bisschen eine andere Struktur.
Aber ich glaube, im Laufe der Jahre sind dann die Leute auch in Kiel und anderen Universitäten auf den Trichter gekommen zu sagen,
es ist doch viel besser, wir machen ein Departement mit einzelnen Richtungen.
Und dass ein Geophysiker dann auch mal was über Fossilien lernt, ist ja gar nicht so schlimm und umgekehrt.
Und das war wirklich so ein zentrales strukturelles Defizit an unseren Universitäten.
Und da habe ich versucht, wegen meiner Ausbildung in den USA und weil ich gerne Sachen infrage gestellt habe,
versucht, das zu überwinden.
Okay, also Sie hatten ein Grundstudium in Deutschland, ich glaube, in Göttingen ging es sogar los?
Ja, ein Semester nur.
Und Freiburg und dann Aachen und dann halt den Ausflug in die USA, kennenlernen eines anderen Forschungsverständnisses.
Völlig.
So würde ich das mal sagen, anderer Umgang, ein etwas übergreifenderer Ansatz,
Dass man eben versucht, da würde ich es mal als holistischen Ansatz interpretieren, man blickt auf alles
und dann kann man eben auch die Verbindungen herstellen.
Da ist so ein bisschen mein Eindruck, bei den Vulkanen kommt dann so alles zusammen.
Während sich die Mineralogen sehr im Detail verfangen können, wie auch andere Spezialitäten,
ist irgendwie das große und ganze Verschmelzen und Explodieren eines Vulkans betrifft irgendwie alle diese Felder.
Ja, das ist eine gute Analogie.
Vielleicht müsste man sagen, dass in den USA nicht nur diese gemeinsame Ausbildung wichtig ist,
sondern auch das menschliche Verhältnis der Professoren zu den Studenten.
Ein ernst nehmen, ganz anders ist als in Deutschland, wo die Professoren doch immer noch die Herrgötter in weiß waren,
so wie in manchen Kliniken.
Und das ist natürlich ganz wichtig für die Ausbildung, man hat dann auch sehr viel Mut,
seine eigenen Ideen zu formulieren und die vorzutragen, man wird ernst genommen.
Und da was ich auch versucht habe, in meinen Studenten zu verwirklichen.
Zurück zu den Vulkanen.
Ich habe dann versucht von Anfang an, die Vulkane in den Doktorarbeiten, in den Exkursionen, in den anderen Kursen
immer als System zu sehen, das reicht vom Erdmantel bis zur Atmosphäre.
Und wir waren dann relativ früh auch dabei, mit zu untersuchen, welche klimatischen Auswirkungen können welche Vulkane haben.
Wir haben am Laacher See Doktorarbeit und dann habe ich eine in Nordkorea.
ich war, glaube ich, der erste westlich Wissenschaftler, der da gearbeitet hat an einem Vulkan, der vor 1000 Jahren ausgebrochen ist.
Und wollte ich rauskriegen, ob die mögliche Klimaveränderung auch die politischen Verhältnisse in dem Korea jener Zeit beeinflusst hat,
dadurch dass durch eine große Klimaveränderung natürlich Wanderungen ausgelöst werden.
Die größten Wanderungen in den USA waren 1816 nach der Eruption eines Vulkans in Indonesien,
der den größten Klima Impact hatte in der Geschichte, in den letzten 200 Jahren,
der auch in Deutschland große Hungersnöte hervorgerufen hat, nicht nur im Süden, sondern auch hier in Norddeutschland.
Im Juni/Juli fiel in Neuengland in den USA noch Schnee und dann gab es eine große Völkerwanderung.
Und das war auch ein sehr schwefelreicher Vulkan ähnlich wie der Laacher See Vulkan.
Also der Vulkan als System, zu dem dann auch die Atmosphäre gehört und darüber dann der Impact auf die Gesellschaft.
Das ist ja die andere Richtung, weil alle Vulkane haben immer die Gesellschaft beeinflusst in den ursprünglichen Gesellschaften.
Ich nenne es immer so, ob das nun in Südamerika ist oder in Indonesien, Bali oder so,
haben die Menschen, die frühen Gesellschaften immer ein duales Bild gehabt von den Vulkanen.
Auf der einen Seite die Fruchtbarkeit, die fruchtbaren Böden und vielleicht Baumaterial
und auf der anderen Seite die Furcht, indem sie dann Götter erfunden haben,
und dann dem gehuldigt haben und Opfergaben gebracht haben, um sie zu beschützen,
damit die Götter nicht ärgerlich werden und die Leute dann töten durch Glutlawinen oder Lavaströme.
Das ist immer das duale Bild eigentlich von vielen Naturgefahren.
Und das gehört, wenn man Vulkane untersucht, immer dazu.
Während zum Beispiel die letzte Doktorarbeit, die gerade fertig wird, von einer sehr hochbegabten Doktorandin,
wir haben rausgekriegt, dass die Eruption des Laacher See Vulkans während der Eruption einen extremen Einfluss hatte auf den Rhein.
Es hat sich erst ein großer Stausee gebildet bei Koblenz, und dann brach der Damm mehrfach
und dann wurde das Ganze, das Neuwieder Becken ist so ein tektonisches Becken,
völlig verwüstet mehrfach und dann kamen Glutlawinen weiter nördlich durch ein tiefes Tal
und haben den Rhein abgesperrt und haben einen vielleicht 100 Meter hohen Damm gebaut
und dann hat sich ein See gebildet dahinter, der dann über den Mittelrhein bis nach Mainz ging.
Das waren also mit Abstand die größten Auswirkungen.
Das heißt, dieser Bereich der Gefahren und der Risiken, man muss das unterscheiden.
Gefahren ist das, was Sachen oder Menschen beschädigt und Risiko ist das, was man in Heller und Pfennig abrechnen kann.
Also das monetäre.
Sie haben ja schon so ein wichtiges Stichwort genannt, Vulkansysteme.
Man hat halt so auf den ersten Blick, da denkt man sich so, okay Vulkan, das ist da halt so der Berg,
wo irgendwie so ein bisschen Lava rauskommt, so, das ist dann irgendwie der Vulkan,
aber das ist ja im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes nur die Spitze des Feuerbergs.
Man muss das Ganze ja viel größer aufspannen, um irgendwie zu verstehen, was eigentlich dort tatsächlich passiert.
Wenn man jetzt mal wirklich das ganze System betrachtet und versucht zu verstehen,
was führt dazu, dass diese Vulkane ausbrechen und was für Kräfte setzen sich dort eigentlich wirklich frei
und vor allem, was für unterschiedliche Ausprägungen von Vulkanen gibt es,
was muss man sich in diesem gesamten System als erstes anschauen, um zu verstehen, was letzten Endes passiert?
Beginnt alles mit der Plattentektonik, ist das der erste Schlüssel, den man sich anschauen sollte?
Ja, Sie haben das Stichwort genannte, Plattentektonik war das, was die Doppelhelix in der Biologie ein paar Jahre vorher war.
Das war die große Revolution.
Zu welchem Zeitpunkt?
Das kann ich Ihnen ziemlich genau sagen, denn 64 wurde ich in den USA promoviert.
An Johns Hopkins war man noch nicht so weit, das war eine ganz tolle Uni,
mit Koryphäen auf verschiednen Gebieten, aber nicht Plattentektonik.
Da war einer im benachbarten Princeton, mit denen hatten wir auch viel Austausch,
der war ein spekulativer Mensch und der hat relativ früh die Vorzeichen für Plattentektonik begriffen und hat spekuliert.
Die Plattentektonik hat nicht direkt was mit Alfred Wegner zu tun, der 1912 über die Verschiebung der Kontinente geschrieben hat,
und ein brillanter Mensch war, mit brillanten Ideen, aber er hat nie über den Mechanismus damals nachdenken können,
das hat erst die Meeresforschung gebracht.
Die haben nämlich in der Mitte zunächst des Atlantiks, das waren englische und amerikanische Wissenschaftler,
die haben gefunden, dass die Mitte des vulkanischen Meeresbodens zur Mitte hin immer jünger wird.
Weil das unterschiedlich lange magnetische Orientierung hatte.
Das kann man datieren.
Die Paleomagentik ist ein zentrales Feld gewesen für die Entwicklung der Theorie der Plattentektonik.
Die dann ein paar Jahre später ergänzt wurde durch die Arbeiten auch eines Princetoners Geophysikers,
der auch mal ein halbes Jahr hier in Kiel war zu Besuch und mit dem wir auch auf die Kanaren gefahren sind,
der hat die Plumetheorie erfunden oder das Modell vorgestellt.
Das heißt, dass aus den Tiefen der Erde Material langsam aufsteigt und beim Aufschmelzen dann,
ich sage mal, 100 Kilometer oder 200 Kilometer Tiefe anfängt zu schmelzen
und dass so die Magmen produziert werden.
Zum Beispiel Hawaii, man nennt das den Plume, den benutzt man auch auf Deutsch den Begriff Plume,
das sind diese Tiefenwurzeln unter Vulkanen.
Und wenn die Erdplatten, Sie hatten die Plattentektonik erwähnt, die wandern ja,
gibt es sieben große und viele kleine Platten, und wenn die über diese, wir nennen das oft, Schmelzanomalie dann drüber wandern,
dann können die Magmen aufsteigen und zum Beispiel Ozeaninseln bilden.
So kann man sehen, es gibt die großen Hawaiianischen Inseln wie Hawaii, Oʻahu und so weiter
und dann viele andere, die nennt man die Emperor Sea Mounts, die sind alle nach japanischen Kaisern benannt,
und die ändern ihre Alter von dem jüngsten, Kīlauea-Vulkan und dann über diese alten in Richtung Japan,
der älteste ist, glaube ich, 60 Millionen Jahre alt, das ist also eine Altersabfolge.
Auch für die Kanaren kann man das sehen, die ältesten sind im Osten, Fuerte Ventura und Lanzarote
und die jüngsten sind da wo gerade die großen Ausbrüche waren, La Palma und El Chichón.
Und das ist die zweite große Theorie gewesen, die die Vulkanologie wesentlich befruchtet hat.
Also der Paläomagnetismus, den Sie ansprechen, das ist ja sozusagen das, sich über die Jahrtausende und Jahrmillionen sich ändernde Magnetfeld der Erde,
ist quasi in den Boden eingegraben, man kann an dem Gestein, was sich dort abgelagert hat, sehen,
zu welchem Zeitpunkt es quasi geformt wurde.
Genau, und zwar sind das die eisenhaltigen Minerale in den Basalten.
Basalt ist das, 99 Prozent aller Magmen auf der Erde sind Basalt.
Da gibt es verschiedene Typen von und wenn die auskristallisieren, dann bilden sie auch kleine Eisen- und Eisentitanoxyde und die sind magnetisch.
Und die Erde hat ein Magnetfeld und wenn so ein Lavastrom ausfließt und abkühlt und dann bildet sich die Richtung,
Nordpol oder Südpol, in diesem Lavastrom ab.
Und wenn das nach ein paar hunderttausend Jahren der Nordpol am Süden ist und der Südpol am Norden,
dann ist das die umgekehrte Orientierung und das kann man messen heute mit verschiedenen Instrumenten.
Und das ist nicht in der Eifel, da hat man das auch gemacht, aber vor allem am Meeresboden die entscheidende Methode gewesen.
Und später die Sedimente, die auf der vulkanischen Ozeankruste lagern.
Ich habe ja auch viele Jahre mit dem Ocaen Drilling gearbeitet, vor allem im Atlantik, aber auch im Pazifik,
da haben wir dann reingebohrt durch die Sedimente und bis in die vulkanischen Gesteine
und haben die dann untersucht, um so die Entwicklung des Meeresbodens und die Plattentektonik natürlich zu rekonstruieren.
Denn USA und Europa die hingen mal zusammen und die sind vor 200 Millionen Jahren,
da hat sich da ein Riss gebildet und das geht weiter auseinander.
Und wenn man das Glück hat, in Island in den zentralen Teil der Insel zu fahren, dann kann man sehen,
wie über, weiß nicht, 10 Kilometer ist die Erdkruste eingebrochen und an beiden Seiten stehen die Basalte höher.
Das ist also lebendiges Sea Floor Spreading, in der Mitte ist das jüngste und dann zu beiden Seiten wird es jeweils älter.
Und sozusagen aus der Betrachtung dieses Paläomagnetismus, der sich im Boden abzeichnet,
wurde sozusagen zu dem Zeitpunkt in den 60er Jahren klar, das muss sich verschieben,
weil das sind alles unterschiedliche Zeiträume, die sich da unten abbilden und daraus entstand überhaupt erst dieses Modell,
okay, diese ganzen Platten schieben sich übereinander, drücken sich hoch und dadurch entstehen diese Brüche quasi in der Erde,
diese Gräben, diese Faltungen, ich weiß nicht genau, wie man es richtig bezeichnen soll
und das ist quasi der Ursprung des Vulkanismus?
Jain, man muss eigentlich zwei Hauptzonen voneinander unterscheiden.
Das eine sind die Zonen, die mittelozeanischen Rücken, wo neue Erdkruste entsteht.
Das wandet auseinander und dann an den Rändern an manchen Kontinenten, nicht an allen,
aber vor allem rings um den Pazifik, das nennt man den pazifischen Feuerring,
und auch in der Karibik, da tauchen diese Platten, das ist jetzt vulkanische Kruste
und darauf liegen ein paar hunderte oder paar tausend Meter Sedimente aus Fossilien und so weiter, die tauchen dort ab.
Rings um die Aleuten, Nordamerika, da wo mein Doktorarbeitsgebiet war, und dann Mexiko, Mittelamerika, Südamerika, bis nach Patagonien.
Und bei diesem Abtauchen der Platten wird in ungefähr 100 Kilometern Tiefe das Wasser aus den Sedimenten frei.
Und wenn das Wasser aufsteigt und mit dem Mantel darüber, da liegt ja dann wieder der Mantel /unverständlich/
von den Kontinenten da drüber, dann kann das Mantelgestein etwas aufschmelzen,
weil die Zugabe von Wasser, das ist jetzt ein petrologisches Problem, erniedrigt den Schmelzpunkt.
Und dann kann dieses Gestein, dieses Mantelgestein ein bisschen aufschmelzen
und dann können die Magmen entstehen und aufsteigen und die sind relativ wasserreich
und darum sind die Vulkane von Südamerika, über Mittelamerika über Aleuten, Japan, Philippinen bis nach Neuseeland,
die sind alle überwiegend relativ explosiv.
Das ist also das Wasser der Ozeansedimente, was dann wieder in dem Magma eingebaut wird
und darum sind diese relativ explosiv.
Die Magmen an den mittelozeanischen Rücken, also wo die /unverständlich/, die sind nicht explosiv, das sind Lavaströme.
Oder untermeerische Lavaströme.
Das heißt, diese Hitze des Magma selber, man würde sich ja jetzt erst mal vorstellen,
so am heißesten ist es natürlich in der Mitte der Erde und da kommt das alles her.
Das ist in dem Sinne gar nicht so, sondern es ist an der Stelle, wo diese Platten aufeinandertreffen
bzw. in dem Moment, wo sie absinken, durch das Mischen mit dem Wasser entsteht überhaupt erst diese Hitze,
die das Magma liefert, was letzten Endes die Vulkane bedient?
Ja, aber nur die Vulkane, die über diesen Subduktionszonen, so nennt man das, liegen.
Das sind auch Teile von Griechenland die Vulkane, Santorini und so oder auch die Äolischen Inseln,
das sind alles solche Subduktionsvulkane.
Der überwiegende Teil der Magmen auf der Erde entsteht durch Druckentlastung an den mittelozeanischen Rücken.
Das ist mit Abstand das meiste Magma, das basaltische Magma, wie auf dem Mond zum Beispiel
und einigen Planeten, das ist basaltisch, das ist das primitive Ausgangsmagma.
Diese explosiven Vulkane, wie der Fuji San oder der Mount St .Helens oder Pinatubo,
das sind sozusagen sekundäre Magmen, die entstehen beim Abtauchen, übrigens so im Pazifik oder rings um Japan,
in Neuseeland, Philippinen, da gibt es auch so Subduktionszonen, da taucht also die ozeanische Platte ab
und dann wird Wasser frei und das fördert die Aufschmelzung vom Mantel.
Also das ist schon so, dass der Kern der Erde ganz heiß ist natürlich, der Erdkern.
Und über dem Erdkern, so in 2900 Kilometer Tiefe, fängt der Erdmantel an.
Und das ist ein Problem, wo viele Geophysiker dran arbeiten, warum fangen einige Teile vom Erdmantel an aufzusteigen?
So wie in einem Wasserkochtopf, wenn von unten aufgeheizt wird, da steigt an einigen Stellen heißes Wasser nach oben und blubbert dann und dampft dann.
Also der Erdmantel, ungefähr 2900 Kilometer dick, der ist nicht stationär,
da finden ganz langsame Bewegungen statt.
Und wenn dieses kristalline, also es besteht aus Kristallen der Erdmantel und wenn Teile davon aufsteigen in,
sagen wir mal, 100 Kilometer oder ungefähr diese Tiefe, dann ist der Druck so niedrig,
dann können einige Minerale anfangen zu schmelzen und Schmelze produzieren.
Und die Schmelze, weil sie leichter ist, die kann dann an /unverständlich/-Grenzen aufsteigen
und sammelt sich, so wie in der Eifel, meistens an der Grenze zwischen Erdmantel und Erdkruste.
Die ist in der Eifel ungefähr 30 Kilometer.
Die Erdkruste ist so der Schaum auf der Erde, der sich im Laufe der letzten 4,5 Milliarden Jahren gebildet hat.
Da, wo wir drauf rumlaufen.
Da, wo wir drauf rumlaufen, Sedimente gefaltet, metamorphisch /unverständlich/ und so weiter und so weiter.
Wo hier wir aus dem Fenster hier die Bauern ihre Felder bestellen, ist die Erdkruste
und die wird natürlich nach unten immer heißer.
Und ungefähr in der Eifel, so ungefähr 30 Kilometer, hier in Schleswig-Holstein wahrscheinlich ähnlich,
da kommt dann plötzlich ein Sprung und dann fangen die schweren, dichten Gesteine des Erdmantels an.
Die bestehen aus Olivin, das ist so typisches Mineral vom Erdmantel und noch ein paar andere.
Und in der Eifel hat man rausgefunden, die Geophysiker schon vor einigen Jahren, arbeiten jetzt wieder dran,
ist das keine scharfe Grenze wie in manchen Gebieten, sondern das ist so paar Kilometer dick.
Und das ist die Schicht, wo sich in der Eifel dann Magmen, wenn sie von unten aufsteigen, sammeln zu einem Reservoir.
Da drüber folgen jetzt diese 30 Kilometer Erdkruste und manchmal wird es den Magmen da in der Tiefe zu viel
oder es wird zu viel gefördert von unten und dann können sie aufsteigen.
Dann bilden sie Risse in der Erdkruste und normalerweise steigen die nicht bis ganz nach oben,
da reicht dann der Auftrieb nicht, dann bilden sie Magmakammern, das ist ein Problem, an dem wir gerade ganz aktuell arbeiten.
In Mare in der Eifel, da haben wir Hinweise, dass sich da so in 20 Kilometern Magmakammern gebildet haben.
Und von da aus kann es dann weitergehen, wenn wieder ein Schwung kommt, mit viel CO2,
mit vielen magmatischen Gasen, dann kann es zu einer Eruption kommen.
Also fast alle Magmen, die da von dieser Grenzschicht kommen, kommen nicht direkt an die Erdoberfläche.
Dazu reicht der Auftrieb nicht und dann bilden sich Magmakammern und in Magmakammern können sich die Magmen wieder verändern,
können sich mehr Gase ansammeln und die haben dann wieder ihren eigenen Druck
und können dann die letzte Wegstrecke aufdrücken.
Mehr oder weniger explosiv.
Ja, die ersten Explosionen in so einem Vulkan die entstehen dann, wenn dieses heiße Magma,
Basalte sind die häufigsten Magmen, die haben so 1100-1200 Grad, sind also sehr heiß,
und wenn die in einen Bereich mit Grundwasser kommen, dann fängt die Explosivität erst richtig an,
weil bei niedrigen Drucken, also paar hundert Meter unter der Erdoberfläche, wenn das Wasser aufgeheizt wird
und zu Dampf umgewandelt wird, das ist dann ein Volumenzuwachs vom Faktor 1000.
Das heißt, plötzlich entsteht da sehr viel Dampf und der übt einen Druck aus und dadurch können dann Teile der allerersten Erdkruste zerbrechen
und dann kann das Magma dann nachkommen.
Das finden wir also an vielen Vulkanen in der Eifel.
Und darum sind wir und meine Studenten versuchen immer, nicht nur ein paar Proben zu nehmen von einem Vulkan,
sondern zu gucken, wie hat was angefangen und wie hat es geendet.
Und da sehen wir in vielen Vulkanen, müssen wir buddeln oft, wo sind die untersten Schichten,
dass da dann Magma mit Wasser reagiert hat, dann findet man viel Nebengestein, also Schiefer oder Sandstein oder was immer
und dass die Magmabestandteile sind vielleicht abgeschrägt, glasig, das zeigt alles, da war Wasser im Spiel.
Und das ist jetzt dieses aktuelle Forschungsprojekt von mir, diese Mare, die für die Touristen besonders attraktiv sind in der Westeifel,
das ist eigentlich der Hauptattraktionspunkt, sind diese Mare.
Wenn man davor steht, dann wird man beinahe ganz ehrfürchtig, weil da offensichtlich eine große Explosion stattgefunden hat.
Also Mare, so ein Vulkankrater, in der Regel mit Wasser gefüllt.
Ja, in manchen trockenen Gegenden ist es auch trocken, aber in Deutschland ist das wassergefüllt.
Und Maare mit AA.
Und drum herum hat man dann so einen Kranz von ausgeworfenem Gestein, viel Nebengestein.
Mit AA.
Und die wurden die letzten 50 Jahre, auch ich selber habe an einigen gearbeitet,
im Lacher See ist ein großes Maar, dass da sehr viel Wechselwirkung zwischen Magma und Grundwasser stattfand.
Und jetzt sind wir dabei, das ist das aktuelle Forschungsprojekt, dass wir sehen im Süden der Westeifel
waren die speziellen Maaren dort sehr sehr CO2-reich und niedrig viskos
und da haben wir Hinweise, dass die schon in etwa 20 Kilometern zerrissen sind,
und zwar bei hohen Temperaturen.
Dass also nicht das Zusammentreffen von Magma und Wasser diese Krater, diese Maarkrater geschaffen hat,
sondern wahrscheinlich Gasexplosionen.
Sie kennen den Spruch, Diamonds are girls best friend.
Schon mal gehört.
Schon mal gehört, wo kommen die Diamanten her?
Die kommen von bestimmten Vulkanen, die nennt man Kimberlit.
In Südafrika, in Sibirien, in Brasilien, in Kanada.
Und das sind ein ganz spezieller Typ von Vulkanen.
Da kommt das Magma aus einer Tief von über 150 Kilometer Tiefe,
also aus sehr großer Tiefe aus dem Erdmantel.
Und nach allem, ich habe noch nie an Kimberliten selber gearbeitet, aber gibt es viele Spezialisten,
sind das Gasvulkane, die durch Kohlendioxid, CO2, das ist ja heutzutage jedermann geläufig das CO2,
was das für eine Rolle spielt, die werden da durchgebohrt durch den Erdmantel und die Kruste
und bei den großen Drucken, über 150 Kilometer Tiefe, entstehen Diamanten, das ist ja Kohlenstoff.
Und da ist dann auch noch die Gasphase dabei, denn auch im Erdmantel gibt es Karbonate.
Also CO2-reiche Minerale, nennt man Dolomit oder Karbonat oder so.
Und diese Maare, die wir jetzt bearbeiten, haben im Prinzip insofern Ähnlichkeit mit diesen Kimberliten,
als sie allerdings nicht von der großen Tiefe, 150 Kilometer, sondern vielleicht 20 Kilometer,
von da war sehr viel CO2 und hat das Magma zerrissen und ist dann als Jet, als Gasjet an die Oberfläche befördert worden.
Ich habe in einem Kapitel in dem Buch, was ich gerade über die Eifel neu schreibe, geschrieben,
es ist nicht so, dass die Orte da, Gillenfeld oder wie die heißen, da jetzt Anziehungspunkt für Diamantenschürfer werden sollen
und auch De Beers hat noch keine Lizenzen beantragt, um da abzubauen.
Das sind also keine Magmen direkt aus dem Erdmantel, sondern aus einer Zwischenstation.
Wieviele Arten von Vulkanen muss man denn dann unterscheiden?
Weil soviel habe ich jetzt schon gelernt, ein Vulkan ist nicht gleich dem anderen Vulkan.
Nur weil irgendwo ein bisschen Magma aus der Erde austritt, ist es nicht unbedingt immer derselbe Prozess, der dort stattfindet.
Sondern die Prozesse, die sich abspielen, hängen davon ab, wo ist es,
was ist sozusagen überhaupt erst mal der Ursprung des aufsteigenden Magmas auf der einen Seite.
Auf der anderen Seite, was die geologische Situation an der Stelle, was befindet sich da?
Ist es da trocken, ist da viel Wasser, so kann man das auf jeden Fall schon mal unterscheiden.
Wie unterschiedlich sind Vulkane und welche Gruppen muss man da unterscheiden?
Also wieviele verschiedene Vulkane gibt es.
Die Basis der Klassifikation ist ja zunächst nach der chemischen Zusammensetzung.
Und damit zusammenhängend dann noch die Mineralogie und wenn man das ganz grob fasst,
sind die mit Abstand meisten Vulkane basaltisch.
Das sind die ganzen Ozeanböden, das sind zwei Drittel unserer Erdoberfläche.
Ist also eine paar Kilometer mächtige basaltische Schicht aus Gängen und aus untermeerischen Laven.
Und auch auf Kontinenten, wenn Sie von der Eifel über den Westerwald gehen und Vogelsberg und weiter nach Osten,
nach Tschechien und in die Lausitz, da sind die allermeisten Vulkane, 95-99 Prozent basaltisch.
Nur wie sie ausbrechen kann sehr unterschiedlich sein.
In meinem Doktorarbeitsgebiet waren das Riesenflächen, da ist ein Basaltstrom, der bedeckte eine Fläche größer als Nordrhein-Westfalen.
Das sind die sogenannten Flutbasalte.
Die findet man auch nicht nur da in Washington und Oregon und Idaho,
sondern auch in Südamerika und in Indien, der ganz südliche Teil von Indien ist von solchen Flutbasalten bedeckt.
Dann gibt es natürlich die explosiven basaltischen Vulkane, wie die Schlackenkegel in der Eifel.
Das sind entweder Schlackenkegel oder es sind Maare, diese Löcher, die ich eben beschrieben habe.
Ja.
So und dann gibt es die, wir sagen, höherdifferenzierten oder fraktionierten Vulkane,
die mehr Gas haben, meistens mehr Silizium oder mehr Aluminium, weniger Magnesium,
weniger Eisen und so weiter und so weiter.
Dazu gehört Laacher See, die nennt man dann Phonolit oder Trachyt.
Gibt es auch so bisschen im Vogelsberg, aber nicht viel.
Vesuv zum Beispiel ist zum Teil sehr höherdifferenziert und natürlich die im pazifischen Feuerring
von Neuseeland über Philippinen und Japan und Aleuten und so weiter,
Kanada, USA bis Mittelamerika und Südamerika.
Das sind explosive Vulkane, da gibt es Namen wie Andesit, ist da ein häufiges Gestein,
kommt natürlich von den Anden.
Das ist so zwischen Mylonit und Basalt, die sind noch nicht so ganz entwickelt, hochentwickelt,
also viele dieser berühmten Vulkane in Chile oder in Peru oder Ecuador oder …
Jetzt muss ich mal eine Erkenntnis reinwerfen, die für Sie wahrscheinlich vollkommen selbstverständlich ist,
aber wo ich vorhin erst mal so ein bisschen meinen Kopf so drum herum legen musste.
Sie klassifizieren die Vulkane nach den Gesteinen, die dort entstehen, die dort sozusagen auftreten
und mit diesem Vulkan geboren werden.
Ja, das ist deshalb richtig, und das ist wiederum mein aktuelles Forschungsprojekt,
dass die Eigenschaften eines Magmas, seine chemischen Eigenschaften, seine Flüssigkeit,
seine Viskosität, wie wir sagen, sein Gasgehalt, die bestimmen im Wesentlichen auch das Eruptionsverhalten.
Und darum ist das für uns die primäre Sache.
Das andere, ob Sie nun Stratovulkane sagen oder so und so, ist eher sekundär.
Also wie der aufgebaut ist meinen Sie?
Wie der aufgebaut ist.
Zum Beispiel kann ich in der Eifel, das ist auch neu, das sehr viel von den Schlackenkegeln in der Westeifel und Osteifel sind ganz unterschiedlich.
Einige haben viele viele kleine hochexplosive ausgebrochen und wenn ich mir angucke,
die haben eine andere Zusammensetzung.
Das ist auch das, was auch ich in der Vergangenheit so pauschal Schlackenkegel genannt habe,
teile ich jetzt in zwei Gruppen unter, weil die Produkte sind so unterschiedlich.
Und wenn ich mir da die Chemie angucken, aha deshalb.
Weil das war so dünnflüssiges Magma und so viel Gas, die sind anders ausgebrochen.
Ich sehe schon, also Ihr Blick auf den Vulkan ist eigentlich viel mehr, das ist so eine Art Gesteinsfabrik.
Ja.
Das ist einfach so der Ort, wo einfach spezielle Gesteinsverbindungen entstehen,
weil es eben der vulkanische Prozess primär ist, der letzten Endes den Erdmantel mit all diesen unterschiedlichen Ausprägungen versorgt.
Und was an einem Vulkan entsteht, ist die Gesamtmischung aus allem, was da zusammengekommen ist
und unter welchen Bedingungen es zusammengekommen ist.
Muss ich ein bisschen ergänzen und modifizieren.
Es ist so, die Erdplatten bestehen aus zwei Teilen, wie gesagt, ob der Schaum der Erde die Erdkruste,
die in der Eifel 30 Kilometer dick ist und hier in Schleswig-Holstein auch so ähnlich,
und dann kommt eine oberste Schicht vom Mantel, die ist in der Eifel 50-100 Kilometer dick
und die ist mit der Erdkruste verschweißt und das sind die Platten.
Und das geht selbst bei Geologen manchmal durcheinander, wenn ich es lese.
Also die Platten bestehen, hat nichts zu tun mit der Erdkruste, die Erdkruste ist nur wie auf einem Kuchen das Frosting oben drauf,
die ist aber mechanisch gekoppelt mit der obersten Schicht vom Mantel.
Und man nennt diese Erdkruste plus diesen Mantel zusammen auch Lithosphäre,
Lithos ist der Stein, die Gesteinsschicht.
So und da drunter folgt, das nennt man dann Asthenosphäre, der mehr primitivere Mantel.
So, wenn jetzt, und das kann man sich als Laie gut vorstellen, im Laufe der Erdgeschichte wird in den tieferen Teilen des Erdmantels,
also in der sogenannten Asthenosphäre, wenn das langsam aufsteigt, entsteht Schmelze, das Magma.
Und die steigt auf, aber hat manchmal nicht die Kraft, bis zur Moho, bis zur Kruste aufzusteigen,
sondern bleibt in der Lithosphäre stecken.
Ich nenne das die Kompostschicht des Mantels, nur ganz privater Ausdruck.
Weil im Laufe der Zeit immer Magma aufsteigt und stecken bleibt.
Ich habe das mal gesehen in Neufundland in Kanada, da ist schon ein Stück Erdmantel hochgehoben,
da kann man diese Gänge sehen, aber sonst ist nur Olivin, sonst ist nur normaler Erdmantel.
So und jetzt kommt wieder so ein, wie gesagt, Plum, so heißer langsamer Strom aus Kristall,
aus größeren Erdtiefen, ist heiß und trifft dann an diese Kompostschicht,
das ist jetzt also ein Ausdruck, den ich jetzt zum ersten Mal in einer Auflage benutze,
ich glaube, den hat niemand benutzt.
Gibt es hier ganz exklusiv vorab.
Ganz exklusiv.
Aber ich glaube, er ist verständlich für einen Laien.
Absolut.
Und jetzt wird das aufgeschmolzen.
Und was schmilzt als erstes?
Das sind die Gänge, nicht die Olivine, nicht das alte Mantelgestein.
Da braucht mehr Temperaturen, sondern diese Gänge schmelzen zuerst.
So und diese Gänge, die vielleicht, was weiß ich, 50 Millionen Jahre alt oder 100 oder 300 Millionen Jahre alt sind die da drin,
die werden jetzt wieder bisschen aufgeschmolzen.
Das heißt, das Magma, was dann an der Moho, an der Grenze zwischen Erdkruste und Erdmantel kommt,
das kommt zum Teil aus größeren Pristinen, ursprünglichen und dann aus dieser Kompostschicht.
Und die Geochemiker, ganz spezielle Arbeitsmethoden, die Isotopen-Geochemiker,
die können, wenn sie jetzt so ein Stück Basalt haben und versuchen da Strontium und Neodym und Blei und so weiter,
Isotopen zu messen, sie sind ja unterschiedlich, jedes Element hat verschiedene Isotopen.
Dann können Sie rauskriegen, okay, das kommt wahrscheinlich aus der Lithosphäre,
das hat da schon lange Zeit gesessen, vielleicht schon seit dem Paläozoikum und ist jetzt wieder aufgeschmolzen.
So, das, was wir hier gerade, ich komme jetzt wieder auf das aktuelle Forschungsprojekt zurück,
die Maare, die wir untersuchen, von denen wir annehmen, dass sie durch magmatische Gase entstanden sind,
die sind wahrscheinlich aus dieser Lithosphäre, die sind, wir sagen, hoch angereichert.
Und dann direkt südlich davon, ganz am jüngsten Zipfel der Westeifel Vulkanfeldes,
da sind ein paar Vulkane, die sind ganz anders und die kommen wahrscheinlich aus größeren Tiefen,
haben eine höhere Viskosität, die haben Schlacken gebildet, haben keine Maare gebildet,
so dass ich annehme, dass dieser Forschungsansatz jetzt ist eigentlich ganz speziell da drauf,
die Eruptionsmechanismen der Vulkane ganz stark mit ihrer chemischen Zusammensetzung zu erklären.
In der Osteifel, da östlich vom Laacher See, Neuwieder Becken, das sind alles sogenannte Basanite,
die sind relativ viskos, da gibt es auch keine Maare in der Osteifel,
die gibt es nur in der Westeifel, wo diese speziellen Magmen vorkommen.
Also man unterscheidet im Erdmantel diese zwei Schichten mindestens.
Das immer neu heißere aufsteigende Material in diesen Plums und dann treffen die auf die,
wie ich es jetzt locker benannt habe, Kompostschicht, wo die alten Gänge drinstecken
und das wird aufgeschmolzen, weil das heißer ist das aufsteigende Material.
Dann können Magmen entstehen und die steigen dann normalerweise nur bis zur Moho,
das ist die Grenze zwischen Kruste und Mantel.
Wobei man nicht immer im Auge behalten muss, dass da eine Grenze ist, die man seismisch sehr gut untersuchen kann,
weil die Geschwindigkeiten sind hoch im Mantel und wenn Erdbebenwellen durch die Erde laufen,
dann sind die ganz anders im Erdmantel als in der Erdkruste, so hat man die Moho ja definiert.
Und die Magmen, die sich dann in dieser Sammelschicht entlang der Moho,
die wie gesagt in der Eifel mehrere Kilometer dick ist, sammelt, ist eine Mischung von Magmen aus der Kompostschicht und Magmen aus der Tiefe.
Und das ist jetzt unser Job, an der Chemie und Mineralogie und so weiter rauszukriegen,
aus welchen Bereich kommen die?
Und wenn wir jetzt auch gleichzeitig vulkanologisch arbeiten, das heißt, uns die Gesteine angucken,
wie explosiv war das, wie sind die geschichtet, war daneben Gestein und so weiter und so weiter,
sind das Schlacken, dann können wir eins und eins zusammenzählen,
dann merken wir plötzlich, dass einige Vulkane haben sich ganz anders entwickelt als andere.
Und wenn wir die dann chemisch analysieren, dann merken wir, das liegt an den unterschiedlichen Magmen,
unterschiedliche Viskosität, unterschiedlicher Gasgehalt, weniger Silizium und Aluminium,
das sind Elemente, die machen ein Magma sehr zähflüssig, Silizium und Aluminium.
Das heißt, wenn ich mir jetzt mal so Ihren Forschungsalltag vorstelle, nehmen wir jetzt mal an,
es gibt jetzt irgendwo einen komplett neuen Vulkanausbruch irgendwo.
Also ich weiß nicht, es gibt wahrscheinlich keine Orte wirklich, wo man nicht schon längst damit gerechnet hat,
wo es schon mal irgendwelche gab so, aber wenn man jetzt vielleicht mal so einen neuen Ausbruch hat
und dann dort anreist und sich irgendwie das ganze Geschehen anschaut.
Ich weiß nicht, aber Sie das mal so aktiv gemacht, jetzt wirklich an einem frischen Vulkan?
Ich glaube so, Ihr Fokus war immer eher, die Orte zu untersuchen, wo im Prinzip das Geschehen schon eine Weile vorbei ist,
aber das dann wirklich von A bis Z aufzuarbeiten oder haben Sie auch mal so direkt am blubbernden Vulkan geforscht?
Ja, habe ich.
69/70 sagte mir ein Studienkollege, der war dann einer der Geologen am Hawaiian Volcano Observatory,
das ist das größte und bekannteste Vulkanobservatorium auf der Welt,
die sitzen auf dem Kilauea-Vulkan und haben da viele klassische Untersuchungen gemacht über die Jahrzehnte.
Auch gerade in den letzten Jahren war es da ja sehr aktiv.
Und der hat gesagt, Hans, wenn du mal einen aktiven Vulkan sehen willst, Ausbrüche, dann komm jetzt.
Ich hatte gerade in Bochum angefangen und habe mich dann ein halbes Jahr beurlauben lassen,
kriegte dann ein Stipendium oder eine Reisebeihilfe, mein Gehalt wurde um die Hälfte gekürzt
und dann habe ich in der Tat viele sehr dramatische Eruptionen beobachten und mit messen können.
Das heißt, die Vorhersage von dem Kollegen war genau richtig.
Er hat gesagt, der Vulkan ist angeschwollen.
Welcher war das?
Kilauea-Vulkan, das ist der aktivste Vulkan auf Hawaii, der Insel Hawaii.
Und die hatten das erste Laser-Geodimeter, Messgerät überhaupt.
Man hat einen Laser und die Laserstrahlen werden rausgeschickt und in zwei-drei Kilometern Tiefe ist ein Spiegel
und da werden die Strahlen zurückgeschickt und aus der Zeitverzögerung kann man die Entfernung.
Und wenn man das alle drei Tage macht, dann kann man messen, ob sich die Strecke vergrößert,
ob der Bauch anschwillt oder ob er in sich zusammensackt.
Das war also damals eine ganz heiße, ganz moderne Methode.
So ein Distanzmesser im Prinzip, wie man ihn heute auch im Baumarkt kriegt, aber halt in dick und fest und ganz neu.
Damals war das brand new, das war ganz neu und hat mich auch sehr beeindruckt.
Und jedenfalls war seine Vorhersage auf den Punkt richtig und darum habe ich die Entwicklung eines neuen Vulkans da im großen Detail beobachten können.
War das dann auch der erste Vulkan, den Sie wirklich aktiv selber haben ausbrechen sehen?
Aber sicher, sicher.
Ja okay.
Darum bin ich ja auch gleich darauf angesprungen, hic rhodus hic salta sozusagen.
Also hätte ja sein können, dass Sie schon mal einen gesehen haben, aber eben nicht gleich parallel dazu aktiv beforscht haben.
Nein, hatte ich nicht.
Aber jetzt kam sozusagen beides gleich zusammen.
Ja, in meinem Arbeitsgebiet, meinem Doktorarbeitsgebiet, die waren so 8-10 Millionen Jahre alt, diese riesigen Lavaströme.
Und ich habe große Lavafontänen, die bis 300 Meter hoch waren, habe ich beobachtet, war so einen Kilometer weg
und dann fielen nachher die obersten Schlacke zurück auf unsere Helme.
Ich war mit einem Studenten, der Nationalparkservice hat uns immer mit dem Walkie-Talkie,
ihr müsst da weg, ihr müsst da weg, aber wir waren so fasziniert.
Wir sind dann weg von diesem kleinen Hügel im Dschungel und dann, als wir weg waren, halbe Stunde später,
war das Gebiet mit einem Meter heißer Schlacke bedeckt, da sind wir also rechtzeitig weg.
Ja und dann die Lavaströme zu beobachten und bis zu einem beinahe Unfall nach dieser großen Eruption,
die den ganzen Tag gedauert hat mit riesigen Lavaströmen und Lavafontänen,
sind wir am nächsten Morgen hin, bin ich mit dem Kollegen hin, um Messungen zu machen
und war ein dünner Lavastrom, der hatte schon eine graue Haut, der war schon bisschen abgekühlt.
Der war nicht sehr tief, vielleicht halben Meter oder so und dann sind wir drüber gegangen
und plötzlich haben wir gemerkt, das bewegt sich noch.
Jetzt war die Frage, zurücklaufen oder drüben bis ans rettende Ufer
und dann sind wir ganz vorsichtig, um nicht zu fallen, sonst wären unsere Hände,
da sind 1000 Grad heiß, sind wir drüber, ich kannte das, ich habe ja mal ein halbes Jahr im Stahlwerk gearbeitet,
daher kannte ich diese heißen Temperaturen.
Und auf der anderen Seite, wir hatten immer unsere Khakihosen und Schuhe, die Hosenbeine waren Zunder,
einfach durch die Strahlungshitze von dem Dings und auch die Sohlen waren kaputt von den Schuhen.
Wieviele Meter mussten Sie da jetzt überbrücken?
Vielleicht so zehn Meter oder so, waren keine riesigen.
Wie weit waren Sie schon, bis Sie gemerkt haben, dass es zu heiß ist?
Es war ungefähr Halbe Halbe, so zehn und zehn Meter.
Naja, Vulkanologen sind normal sehr vorsichtige Leute.
Sie müssen natürlich, das sind ja keine Abenteurer, und die Leute, die Sie manchmal sehen im Fernsehen mit den Aluminiummänteln,
das ist immer nur für das Fernsehen.
Die Leute in der Vulkanologie die hatten auch mal so Aluminiummäntel, die haben sie der Feuerwehr geschenkt.
Weil in diesem Aluminium kann man nicht arbeiten und auch mit Gasmasken kann man nicht arbeiten.
Gasmasken sind was schreckliches.
Mir hat immer gereicht ein Taschentuch gegen das Schwefel.
Schwefel ist, das war auch in La Palma ein Problem, die waren sehr schwefelreich die Eruptionen,
jetzt im vergangenen halben Jahr.
Das ist ein unangenehmes Problem.
Wenn man direkt vor Ort arbeitet an einem Krater, dann kann man schon eine Gasmaske benutzen,
aber wenn man viel rumläuft und Proben sammelt und Messungen, dann sind Gasmasken sehr hinderlich
und Aluminiummäntel im Normalfall sowieso.
Das ist also meistens for Show, was man sieht.
Wie sind Sie denn jetzt über den Lavastrom rübergekommen?
Vorsichtig.
Aber dann einfach weitergelaufen?
Ja und danach da war das Ende von dem Frischen.
Da waren also viele Lavaströme vom vergangenen Tag und auf der anderen Seite, der war aber nicht so groß,
der hat dann irgendwo aufgehört, dann sind wir halt drumrum gegangen natürlich.
Okay, ich sehe schon, Sie sehen das alles ganz cool.
Ja, es passiert auch selten was.
Einmal ist ein Student mit dem Fuß in so eine fließende Lava gekommen,
der war dann ein paar Wochen im Krankenhaus, aber die Leute sind alle sehr vorsichtig.
Ich war ja gerade in La Palma und ich habe mir die Überbleibsel des letzten Ausbruchs am Cumbre Vieja angeschaut.
Mein erster Kontakt, muss ich sagen, mit etwas, was noch so frisch und auch noch warm war.
Also es war jetzt nicht heiß, aber es war, wenn man drüber gelaufen ist, über dieses Lavalfeld,
hat man nach ein paar Metern schon gemerkt, so da ist was drunter, da ist irgendwie eine ganze Menge an Wärme am Start.
Und alles war, es war irgendwie ein irres Gefühl, weil es klirrt alles, als würde man über Glas laufen.
Man hat ja irgendwie mehr so das Gefühl, ja das ist ja alles Stein, was da rauskommt, scharfkantig.
Und noch viel Schwefel wahrscheinlich in der Luft.
Habe ich jetzt nicht so gerochen, also vom Geruch her war ich jetzt nicht alarmiert.
Aber was mir dann die Leute alle gesagt haben, die den Ausbruch jetzt auch wirklich miterlebt haben,
teilweise auch viel Glück gehabt haben, weil der Lavastrom so direkt neben ihrem Haus lang gezogen ist,
dass es halt ein unfassbarer Lärm gewesen wäre, 24 Stunden am Tag, als würde man direkt neben so einem Flughafen,
wo die ganze Zeit Flugzeuge.
Das Röhren in den Schloten, ja.
Ich kann das nicht beschreiben, also es machte auf mich auch so den Eindruck,
dass man es nicht beschreiben kann, aber wie war es denn in Hawaii in dem Moment?
Mit was für Geräuschen geht denn das einher?
Weil die Bilder kennt man, aber mit den Geräuschen eines Vulkans,
das ist genauso, als wenn man sich so ein Video anschaut, wie eine Rakete startet,
das kann man sich dann irgendwie akustisch auch nicht vorstellen.
Es ist praktisch das gleiche Geräusch wie ein großer Jet.
Wenn ein großes Flugzeug startet, da werden ja auch die Gase mit großer Geschwindigkeit rausgezischt,
rausgedrückt, ich weiß nicht, wie man das beschreiben soll.
Denn es ist ja ein Strom von Gas mit Partikeln,
die jetzt mit großer Geschwindigkeit durch eine Öffnung von vielleicht 50 Metern, nicht viel mehr, durchgeschossen wird.
Und der Auftrieb kommt von den Gasen, was ich vorhin versucht habe zu erklären mit der Eifel, mit den Vulkanen.
Es gibt ja verschiedene Gase.
Die drei bekanntesten, CO2, H2O und Schwefel.
CO2, Kohlendioxid, ist am wenigsten löslich.
Also was zuerst auch am berühmten Kīlauea-Lava-See,
das ist so der zentrale Lavasee da am Kīlauea.
Das erste Gas, was rauskommt, ist immer CO2, Kohlendioxid.
Und dann, wenn Lava oder Magma ein paar hundert Meter unter der Erdoberfläche,
das ist so typisch in Hawaii, lateral wandert, innerhalb von Gängen
und dann ausbricht an irgendeiner Stelle, wie die meisten Vulkane am Kilauea, dann ist CO2 zum Teil schon weg,
das geht durch das Zentrum weg und dann ist das Hauptgas H2O.
So und dann ist es interessant, wenn man so einen Lavastrom, Kilauea, der braucht ungefähr 10 Kilometer bis zum Pazifik
und manchmal gibt es Fenster, das ist eingebrochen, da kann man sehen, da fließt der Lavastrom unterirdisch,
so ein, zwei Meter da drunter.
Und wenn man da misst, dann hat man meistens Schwefel.
Und wenn der Lavastrom nach 10 Kilometern am Pazifik ist, dann ist auch Schwefel weg.
Das heißt, diese verschiedenen Gasspezies, CO2, H2O und Schwefel, die haben unterschiedliche Löslichkeiten.
Am wenigsten löslich ist CO2, darum ist das auch, nicht umsonst gibt es viele Sprudelfirmen in der Eifel.
Mineralwasser.
Mineralwasser. Und zum Teil ist das natürliches CO2, was da bis zur Erdoberfläche kommt
und Säuerlinge macht, so Sauerquellen und so.
Das heißt, ein Teil der Magmen, die jetzt an der Moho, was ich vorhin beschrieben habe,
zwischengelagert werden, die können da schon ihr Gas loswerden.
Und da gibt es in der Eifel auch große Verwerfungen, also die Kruste ist nicht so homogen,
die ist nicht nur geschichtet, sondern da sind auch große Verwerfungen drin.
Und so ein Gas ist ja nicht blöd, das versucht natürlich da aufzusteigen, wo so tektonische Verwerfungen sind.
Und an diesen großen Verwerfungen da findet man dann oft so vor allem CO2 und auch Vulkaneruptionen.
So wie unser Projekt, was wir gerade anfangen, da ist auch eine große Verwertung in der Gegend.
Okay und das heißt vor allem, dass der Wasserdampf drückt jetzt quasi mit dem Magma aus diesem überschaubaren Krater raus
und das erzeugt diesen Lärm?
Ich weiß nicht, soweit ich gehört habe, waren die Zusammensetzungen in La Palma, jetzt im vergangenen Jahr die Eruption,
relativ schwefelreich.
Okay, gut, also welche Gase auch immer es in dem Moment sind, aber das ist sozusagen der Effekt,
der letzten Endes diesen Lärm erzeugt, zusätzlich mit den ganzen…
Wenn Sie einen Wasserkessel haben mit einer Pfeife oben drauf und dann kriegen Sie genug Dampf.
Das heißt, ich muss mir das jetzt wirklich so vorstellen, als würde man wirklich direkt neben einem Flugzeug stehen?
Ja.
So laut die ganze Zeit?
So, dass man sich gar nicht unterhalten kann?
Also im Prinzip der Wasserkessel.
Ja, da steht man auch nicht so gerne die ganze Zeit daneben.
Der altertümliche, der noch pfeift.
Haben wir gar nicht mehr.
Ich habe so was noch.
Sie kennen es noch?
Ja, Milchtopf.
Also es ist das gleiche physikalische Prinzip.
Wie ging es Ihnen denn dann?
Also ich meine, das ist doch irgendwie ein monumentales Ereignis, wenn man so was das erste Mal irgendwie so,
also man nähert sich dem ja aus der Ferne, da muss man das ja schon über Kilometer grollen hören oder nicht?
Ja, natürlich.
Und das zusammen mit dem Optischen.
Also diese vier, fünf Stunden, die ich da mit dem einen Kollegen verbracht habe, auf diesem alten kleinen Schlackenkegel im Dschungel
und das andere Gebiet hatte ich schon Wochen vorher immer wieder besucht und Messungen gemacht und so weiter,
und da kam nur die Lava an der einen Stelle raus, floss ein bisschen und da war ein Loch 50 Meter weiter und verschwand wieder.
Und dann waren die Messungen mit dem Lasergerät waren dann so, dass wir wussten,
der Vulkan ist angeschwollen und man dann heutzutage schon Vulkaneruptionen relativ gut vorhersagen.
Man weiß ja, wann das Dach nachgibt, das sind Erfahrungswerte.
Also wenn man zumindest einen Krater schon hat, den man beobachten kann.
Muss kein Krater sein.
Aber in La Palma da wusste man es ja nicht, dass der Ausbruch bevorsteht so richtig oder?
Also die 49er Eruption, die wir ja nun sehr genau bearbeitet haben, da war ein Krater,
der war direkt neben dem jetzigen und dann waren noch zwei oben auf der Cumbre, auf dem Gipfel.
Das eine war eine Eruption Magma und Wasser und das andere war eine normale heiße Eruption.
Ein Lavastrom ist auf die andere Seite geflossen, in den Atlantik.
Also da waren drei Stellen.
Dieser Vulkan hat nur im Prinzip eine Stelle gehabt, da am Fuße der Cumbre Vieja.
Aber ganz daneben und der Lavastrom vom 49er, den wir bearbeitet haben, der auch ein Delta gebildet hat,
der ist ja direkt daneben, in Karten, wenn man sieht, wo der neue ist, der ist direkt neben dem.
Das heißt, das ist jetzt wieder das Problem, wie lang hält das Gedächtnis bei den Menschen an,
wenn einem Gebiet, wo es sogenannte Naturereignisse, die manchmal Naturkatastrophen genannt werden, sind.
Das kennt man sehr gut aus den USA, weil dort die Bevölkerung in den kleinen Städten sehr mobil ist.
Eine mittlere Stadt, 30.000 Leute, die wechselt einmal in, weiß nicht, 50 Jahren, die sind sehr mobil.
Und es gibt Bereiche in Oregon und Kalifornien, wo Leute ihre Häuser an den Steilküsten bauen.
Und nach zwei Jahren, nach einem großen Sturm, fallen die meisten Häuser wieder ins Wasser.
Das heißt, das Gedächtnis der Leute, was Naturereignisse oder sogenannte Naturgefahren betrifft, ist sehr kurz.
Und das jetzt auf La Palma übertragen.
Die 49er Eruption war ja nicht die erste.
Es gibt ja nun seit die Spanier oder ihre Vorfahren da im 14. Jahrhundert auf La Palma kam,
hat man ja ein halbes Dutzend Eruption, die sind auch kartiert und so.
Das heißt, die Leute dort wissen, alle paar Dekaden im Mittel, weiß nicht, 50 oder 60 Jahren bricht da ein Vulkan aus.
Wenn ich Versicherungsmakler wäre, ich weiß nicht, wie die Leute mit ihren Häusern da versichert waren,
wenn ich Versicherungsmakler wäre und geologisch, vulkanologisch fit, dann würde ich sagen,
hier das war 1949 und da waren die anderen, in einem Umkreis von so vielen Quadratkilometern müsst ihr das vierfache bezahlen an Hausversicherung.
Denn innerhalb von einem halben Jahrhundert wird hier wieder ein Lavastrom langließen.
Die Menschen denken aber nicht so weit, die denken kurzfristiger.
Nicht hier auf dem Land in Schleswig-Holstein, hier ist ein …
Gibt es nicht so viele Vulkane.
Da gibt es nicht so viele Vulkane.
Also versichert waren tatsächlich nicht so viele auf La Palma.
Wie ich gehört habe, hat der Staat dann kurzfristig den Leuten noch die Möglichkeit gegeben,
abgesichert durch den Staat, noch eine Versicherung abzuschließen, die dann greift,
wenn ihr Haus und Hof nicht innerhalb der nächsten sieben Tage betroffen ist.
Also man konnte sich dann sozusagen noch retten.
Wieviele das dann getan haben, darüber habe ich keine Erkenntnis,
aber das war dann so bisschen die Notlösung, die man dort gefunden hat.
Ja, also wenn ich über Vulkangefahren in der Eifel spreche, als ich anfing 1970, da hieß es,
der Vulkanismus ist erloschen.
Und ein paar Jahre später, ich weiß nicht, 1976 hat der damalige Präsident der DFG,
Deutschen Forschungsgemeinschaft, ein Geologe, ein Buch geschrieben über Naturgefahren
und da steht der klassische Satz drin, zum Glück ist der Vulkanismus in der Eifel erloschen.
Das war schon damals absoluter Unsinn, denn man wusste vorher die Laacher See Eruption, eine sehr große Eruption,
war nicht die letzte, Ulmen in /unverständlich/ ist noch jünger, ist 11.000 Jahre alt.
Und die ersten Datierungen /unverständlich/, der Erfinder der C14 Datierungsmethoden gemacht hat,
das erste Holz war vom Laacher See.
So 11.000 Jahre ist keine Zeit.
Und wir in der Vulkanologie sagen, alle Eruptionen aller Vulkane, die noch nach der letzten Eiszeit ausgebrochen sind,
also in den letzten 15.000 Jahren, die gelten definitionsgemäß als aktiv.
Das heißt, der Laacher See Vulkan ist aktiv formal und Ulmen ist auch aktiv.
So, ich habe also seit 1970 auch schon da in den Veröffentlichungen den Leuten gesagt,
ihr müsst keine Angst haben, die Grundstückspreise müssen nicht fallen, hier rings um den Laacher See oder sonst wo,
aber ihr müsst wissen, es kann jederzeit wieder ein neuer Vulkan ausbrechen und das wird es auch.
Nur kann ich nicht sagen, niemand kann das sagen, ob das in 5.000 Jahren ist oder in 10.000.
Und in dem Gebiet, wo ich jetzt arbeite, da ist der Unterschied zwischen Vulkanaltern 5000-7000 Jahre, das ist keine Zahl.
Wenn wir die Klimakatastrophe überleben, dann sind ein paar tausend Jahre, das ist ein bisschen länger als La Palma,
La Palma ist ein hochaktives Gebiet, aber in der Eifel kann auch jederzeit ein neuer Vulkan ausbrechen,
nur müssen die Leute keine Angst haben und die müssen ihre Grundstücke nicht verkaufen.
Also die Eifel hat es zwar noch vor sich, aber man muss jetzt nicht gleich in Panik ausbrechen, so deute ich das jetzt mal.
Wir wollen ja den Leuten aus der Eifel ja jetzt nicht Angst machen.
Sie können da durchaus Urlaub machen oder ein Grundstück kaufen oder was auch immer.
Ich würde noch mal gerne auf die Forschung vor Ort kommen.
Und vielleicht bleiben wir bei diesem Hawaii Beispiel, weil das ja so ein gutes Timing war.
Abgesehen von diesen Laserdistanzmessungen, die gemacht wurden und die ja letzten Endes die Basis der Aussage war…
Der Vorhersage, ja.
…hier geht es bald los, genau, das war so die Vorhersage.
Was haben Sie sich denn dann angeschaut?
Also was genau macht man denn dann da?
Ich meine, da ist ein riesiges Gebiet, das ist ein Höllenlärm, Lava strömt durch die Gegend,
man muss aufpassen, dass man sich nicht mal eben seinen Fuß abbrüht.
Was sind die Dinge, die Sie dann einfangen wollen?
Was wird gemessen?
Worauf stürzt man sich da und wie plant man das?
Ja, also in dem Augenblick, was man macht, abgesehen davon, dass man ganz tief beeindruckt ist,
fotografiert man und ich habe ja dann auch zum ersten und einzigen Mal in meinem Leben mir einen Kodak-Filmgerät geliehen da
und einen Film, ich weiß nicht, 10 Millimeter, glaube ich, und das war nachher die Basis,
weil mein Gehalt ja gekürzt war in Bochum.
In welchem Jahr war das jetzt dieser Ausbruch?
1970.
70.
Dass ich den an das WDR verkauft habe, die fanden den so toll und dadurch einen Teil von dem Verlust dadurch ausgeglichen habe.
Also das ist das eine und auch viele 6x6 Fotos, ich hatte noch meine Rollei Damals.
Okay, aber das war ja jetzt eher die Wissenschaftsfinanzierung, noch nicht die Wissenschaft selber.
Doch doch, das ist natürlich Wissenschaft, die fotografische Dokumentation.
Die ist in all unseren Büchern ganz zentral.
Und bei diesem Buch „Vulcanism“, was das Standarbuch war oder die japanische Übersetzung, ist ja oft beschrieben worden
und ein bekannter Kollege hat geschrieben, das seien die besten Vulkanfotos, die er gesehen hat.
Und das liegt daran, man nimmt meistens Menschen als Maßstab, wenn möglich
und normalerweise stellen sich die Menschen dann so hin und gucken einen doof an und dann kann man ein Foto machen.
Ich habe die Menschen immer umgedreht, das heißt, dass die Menschen auf den Gegenstand gucken,
um den Betrachter da mit einzubinden, dass er sozusagen diesem Maßstabmenschen folgt.
Damit man auch gleich weiß, worauf man achten soll.
Genau, zum Beispiel, das ist so ein automatischer, kein erdachter Trick, der von mir ganz automatisch,
um die Beobachter zu zwingen, da hinzugucken.
Also die fotografische Dokumentation oder durch Film oder was immer heutzutage Podcasts oder so mit den Geräuschen, ist schon ganz zentral.
Und man hat meistens, das ist ja sehr heiß und sehr laut und dramatisch.
Die genauen Messungen kommen dann hinterher, wenn die Eruption vorbei ist.
Wenn man ganz spezialisiert ist, kann man an einer Stelle Gase messen
oder Temperaturen messen, das sind so zwei ganz häufige Sachen.
Und dann nimmt man Proben, da macht man Dünnschliffe, bis hin zu 25.000tel Millimeter dick
und die kann man dann im Mikroskop untersuchen, ich habe oben meine Mikroskope, mache ich alle paar Tage.
Und dann im mikroskopischen Bild kann man die Kristalle sehen, die aus der Schmelze auskristallisiert sind
und kann sehen, ist das Glas, wieviele Blasen, was für Blasen sind da, welche Korngröße und alle diese Sachen,
die wir standardmäßig machen.
Und dann kann man eine Probe zermahlen in so einem bestimmten Apparat zu Pulver
und die dann chemisch analysieren.
Und die Dünnschliffe kann man unter ein Gerät legen, das nennen wir Elektronmikrosonde,
das habe ich hier auch, damals von meinem Preis gekauft, als ich hier anfing in Kiel.
Jetzt haben wir schon die zweite Generation oder meine Nachfolger.
Ich bin ja schon etliche Jahre nicht mehr dabei.
Aber meine Frau hat gestern wieder Messungen gemacht da am Geomar, das ist so 20 Kilometer weg von hier.
Und dann kann man das Glas analysieren, die Mineralen, die einzelnen Elementverteilungen
und das braucht man so als Grundlage, um das ganze chemisch und mineralogisch in den Griff zu kriegen.
Also Ihre Frage vorher, ich weiß nicht, vielleicht war das neu für Sie,
dass man Vulkane auch ganz zentral von der Chemie und Mineralogie her begreift.
Weil die Art, wie ein Vulkan ausbricht, hängt ganz wesentlich davon ab.
Woraus er beschaffen ist.
Woraus er beschaffen ist, was er mitgekriegt hat als Erbe aus dem Mantel
oder was er in einer Magmakammer dann entwickelt hat, als es ein bisschen kühler war
und dann sind einzelne Kristalle ausgeschieden und so weiter und so fort.
Also bei allen unseren Arbeiten spielt immer die Chemie, die Glaschemie, die Gesteinschemie, die Mineralen eine Rolle.
Und man kann auch der Chemie ausrechnen, welche Viskosität hatte das Magma, wie dünnflüssig oder schwerflüssig.
Ich habe zum Beispiel bei den Bildern von La Palma mich ein bisschen gewundert.
Was mir aufgefallen ist, dass die Lavaströme relativ dick waren und zerbrochen sind in so Schlacken.
Bei der 49er-Eruption, die wir ja sehr gut kennen, ist der Lavastrom,
der direkt neben den jetzigen Kratern ausgebrochen ist, das war eine sehr primitive Zusammensetzung und dünnflüssig.
Der ist also runtergeflossen bis zum Meer und hat da ein Delta gebildet.
Während mit ein bisschen Zeitverschiebung waren drei Stellen, die sich oben gebildet haben auf dem Gipfel, auf der Cumbre,
die waren viskoser und ich glaube, ich habe die chemischen Zusammensetzungen nicht gesehen von der jetzigen Lava,
wenn ich mir die angucke, dann würde ich erwarten, dass die im Vergleich zu dem neuen /unverständlich/-Lavastrom,
der von ganz daneben runtergekommen ist, dass da Unterschiede sind.
Dieser 49er da, das war das Hauptvolumen, der ist sehr schnell geflossen, wie man aus Berichten ablesen kann,
der hat sich seinen Kanal gefressen, Lava kann auch den Untergrund aufschmelzen
und ist dann runter und am Meer hat er dann das Delta gebildet.
Während die jetzigen nach meiner phänomenologischen Analyse vom Fernsehen wohl eine andere Zusammensetzung gehabt haben müssen.
Also dünnflüssig kam mir das jetzt nicht vor, aber ich habe auch keine Ahnung,
wie das alles dann am Ende aussehen soll, wenn es kalt ist.
Wie gesagt, das war ein einziges Geklirre und alles war sehr unzusammenhängend.
Also es war nicht so, man hätte sich jetzt ja vielleicht vorgestellt, dass es irgendwie so ein dicker geschmolzener Block von Stein,
der dann da einfach so rumliegt, aber ich hatte eher das Gefühl, ich habe so eine ganze Badewanne voll mit kleinen Steinchen,
in denen ich irgendwie herumlaufe.
Ja, also Sie haben vorhin gefragt, wie man Vulkane voneinander unterscheidet,
bei den Lavaströmen gibt es zwei altbekannte Unterscheidungen.
Das eine sind die wulstförmigen Laven, die sogenannte Pahoehoe-Laven,
die bildet sich bei dünnflüssigen Lavaströmen, man kann das auch am Vesuv sehen.
Was ich gesehen habe von den Lavaströmen im vergangenen Jahr in La Palma aus den Fernsehberichten
und ich habe ja ein paarmal auch kommentiert, was man da sieht, das sah für mich so aus,
als ob das eine zähflüssigere Schmelze war, die dann zerbrochen ist in einzelne mehr oder weniger blasige Brocken beim Fließen.
Man kann das auch Brockenlava nennen, da gibt es so verschiedene Begriffe.
Insofern kann ich als doch ziemlich erfahrener Vulkanologe sagen,
von der chemischen Zusammensetzung her muss das anders sein als diese Seillava,
die bei der einen Phase, nicht bei der ersten, bei der zweiten Phase der 49er Eruption.
Das ist wie ein Wasser den Berg runtegelaufen.
Wenn man jetzt mal so heute auf die Welt schaut, was sind denn so die aktivsten
oder könnte man vielleicht auch sagen, interessantestes Gebiete aus Ihrer Perspektive,
wo am meisten interessantes passiert, also auch aus einer wissenschaftlichen Perspektive.
Ich meine, es gab ja sehr unterschiedliche Ausbrüche, gerade jetzt so in der letzten Zeit war ja irgendwie eine ganze Menge los.
Vielleicht ist auch immer so viel los, ich weiß nicht, ob da noch mehr drüber berichtet wird
oder ich es nur mehr wahrgenommen habe, es gab diesen Ausbruch auf Island,
der irgendwie eine Weile alle ganz gut unterhalten hat, dann natürlich der große Ausbruch in La Palma,
den wir schon angesprochen haben, der Ätna kommt irgendwie alle paar Monate und sagt irgendwie kurz Bescheid.
Daran hat man sich schon irgendwie so ein bisschen gewöhnt.
Wo würden Sie mich denn jetzt als erstes hinschicken, wenn Ausbruch ist,
weil das irgendwie besonders interessant sein könnte.
So wie Beauty is in the eye of the beholder, das hängt jetzt ab von dem Interesse eines Menschen.
Für mich zum Beispiel ist im Augenblick interessanter das Pulvermaar und die /unverständlich/-Maare,
weil wir da ein neues Paradigma, das alte schon, das hängt also da mit dem Interesse ab.
Wenn Sie fragen wollen oder wissen wollen, wo ist die größte Wahrscheinlichkeit,
dann würde ich sagen, nehmen Sie sich ein Flugticket zum Kilauea-Vulkan auf Hawaii,
da ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit am größten, das ist der aktivste Vulkan mit Lavaströmen, die Wahrscheinlichkeit ist dann groß.
Es hat mal einen Wissenschaftler gegeben, früher durften die nur alle zwei Jahre da arbeiten,
dann wurden sie ausgetauscht vom US /unverständlich/ Survey und der hat Zeit seines Lebens nicht vergessen,
dass er während seines zweijährigen Aufenthaltes keine einzige Eruption gesehen hat, das muss aber der einzige sein.
Wenn Sie auf jeden Fall eine Eruption sehen wollen, morgen oder übermorgen oder überübermorgen,
dann fahren Sie nach Neapel und fahren dann mit dem Schiff zum Stromboli.
Der hieß im Mittelalter oder vorher noch schon, der Leuchtturm des Mittelalters,
weil der alle sagen wir mal 20 Minuten ausbricht.
Dann kriegen Sie kleine Lavafontänen, ganz selten, dass da mal eine längere Pause ist.
Also Stromboli da können Sie drauf wetten.
Da ist richtig was los.
Da ist immer was los.
Okay.
Wenn Sie richtig große Eruptionen, dann gehen Sie nach Hawaii.
Wenn Sie auch gern mal japanische Kultur kennenlernen wollen, dann fahren Sie nach Kyushu, im Süden von Japan.
Da ist eine Stadt, Kagoshima und gegenüber ist der aktivste Vulkan Japans, der fast dauertätig ist.
Das sieht man von der Entfernung, dann spuckt der und hat mal große Aschesäulen, die dann entstehen,
mal stärker und mal weniger stark, der Sakurajima, so heißt der.
Das ist der aktivste Vulkan Japans, praktisch daueraktiv.
Natürlich ist Island in fast regelmäßigen Abständen aktiv, aber nicht jedes Jahr.
Nicht immer an der gleichen Stelle.
Nicht jedes Jahr, nicht die gleiche Stelle.
Natürlich, wir haben auch am Merapi gearbeitet, das ist der aktivste Vulkan in Indonesien,
der ist jetzt gerade im Augenblick wieder aktiv und da sind die Zeiten zwischen aktiven Perioden nur kurz,
so ein paar Jahre, aber der ist nicht einfach, um hinzugehen, geht meistens nicht oder nicht ganz nah dran,
weil da heiße Schmelze rauskommt, das nennen wir Dome.
Und wenn die kollabieren, dann gibt es Glutlawinen.
Und Glutlawinen sind mit das gefährlichste bei Vulkanen, das ein Gemisch ist von Partikeln und aufgeheizter Luft
und heißen Gasen und die können mit großer Geschwindigkeit durch die Täler fließen,
da wo auch die Menschen sich bewegen.
Ist das jetzt identisch mit den pyroklastischen?
Ist dasselbe, ich benutze für Laien den Begriff Glutlawinen, aber einige Leute wissen heutzutage,
kennen schon den Begriff pyroklastische Ströme.
Und wenn man noch weiter in die ganz spezielle Wissenschaft geht, dann nennt man die Density Currents,
aber ich benutze eigentlich pyroklastische Ströme normalerweise auch in meinen Büchern.
Oder wir haben ja auch mal ein Kinderbuch geschrieben hier, was auch Erwachsene gerne sich angucken,
da spreche ich natürlich von Glutlawinen.
Das bringt es natürlich ganz gut rüber, dass es hier sich um einen sehr schnellen Prozess handelt,
der halt auch potentiell gefährlich sein kann.
Was sind denn so die anderen Gefährdungen, die von den Vulkanen noch ausgehen?
Ich erinnere mich noch an den Ausbruch in Island.
Eyjafjallajökull?
Super. Wie lange muss man das üben?
Wir haben ja auf Island gearbeitet, also…
Da hat man es drauf, die Wikipedia sagt, man kann auch Eyjafjöllgletscher sagen und dann ist auch alles super.
Okay.
Auf jeden Fall das war ja ein interessanter Ausbruch, ist jetzt zwölf Jahre her, ich glaube, 2010 war das,
weil dort Unmengen an Vulkanasche ausgestoßen wurden und das hatte ja dann zur Folge,
dass in Europa die Flüge ausgesetzt werden mussten für ein paar Tage
und der Flugverkehr enorm davon betroffen war, weil einfach diese Vielzahl von Aschepartikeln in der Luft potenziell die Turbinen der Jets hätte zerstören können,
so war zumindest die Befürchtung.
Jetzt ist ja nicht jeder Ausbruch so.
Es gab ja jetzt diesen anderen Ausbruch in Island paar Meter weiter, da war von Asche nicht die Rede.
Was führt denn dazu, dass so ein gigantischer Ascheausstoß stattfindet, was ist denn da sozusagen das Wesen dieses Vulkans gewesen?
Das Transportmittel für Asche außerhalb der Eruptionssäule, wir nennen das, was in de Luft geht, Eruptionssäule.
Die Kraft der Eruptionssäulen beruht einmal auf der Temperatur der Partikel und dann der aufgeheizten kalten Luft, die gesaugt wird.
Das ist oft der Hauptteil, die wiederum kriegt dann einen Auftrieb, wie heiße Luft im Sommer aufsteigt.
Die feinen Aschen, das sind ja alles Glaspartikel und Mineralpartikel, hat ja nichts mit normaler Asche zu tun.
Das ist immer die Schwierigkeit mit normalen Laien und Aschen, dann denken sie an Lagerfeuer
oder an die Zigarette oder was weiß ich, sondern das sind Glassplitter und Mineralsplitter.
Manchmal mit Blasen wie bei Bims und manchmal mit weniger Blasen.
So, wenn die jetzt in die Troposphäre und bei 12 Kilometer bis in die Stratosphäre,
da fängt die Stratosphäre an, wo es keine Wolken mehr gibt und keinen Regen,
transportiert werden, aufsteigen, dann werden sie lateral transportiert,
vor allem von dem Jet, von den Höhenwinden und das kann über tausende Kilometer sein.
So, das Problem ist, dass die Höhe der unteren Luftschicht, der Troposphäre, zu den Polen hin immer niedriger wird.
Die ist bei dem Äquator ungefähr 16 Kilometer hoch diese Grenze zwischen der unteren Atmosphäre und dann der Stratosphäre
und zu den Polen hin wird es eben dann niedriger.
Und Island hat den Vorteil oder den Nachteil, je nachdem, dass diese Grenze niedrig ist.
Verstehe.
Das heißt, die Eruption war gar nicht so außergewöhnlich, aber es wehten starke Winde,
die diese Glaspartikel, also diese Asche hier hingetrieben haben.
So übrigens der Kollege und Studienkollege, der mich nach Hawaii eingeladen hat 1969,
da war ich ja ein Dreivierteljahr da, der war gerade auf dem Weg zu einem Ferienaufenthalt,
ich glaube, in Ägypten und der kam nur bis Paris und konnte nicht weiter wegen der Eruption
als Vulkanologe in Island.
So und in Island ist diese Grenze nur 9 Kilometer, bei uns ist sie 12.
Das heißt, obwohl die Eruptionssäule gar nicht so extrem hoch war, waren die Höhenwinde schon
und das war ein starker Westwind zu der Zeit, das ist ein Teil von diesem Dilemma.
Und das andere sind bestimmte Politika.
Das ist der andere Teil der ganzen Story.
Vor allem der deutsche Verkehrsminister, der sich da ins Zeug gelegt hat,
und Wissenschaftler, die sind schon mit kleinen Flugzeugen schon am nächsten Tag hoch geflogen in den Bereich
und haben gesagt, da ist fast gar nichts.
Das heißt, ich glaube, ein Teil von diesem Billionenschaden, der entstanden ist,
geht auf das Konto von öffentlichkeitsaffinen Politikern, die dann gesagt haben,
jetzt muss das noch mal und noch einen Tag und noch einen Tag verlängert werden.
Einige Wissenschaftler, die dann nicht direkt so mit der Politik verbunden waren, die sagen, das ist Quatsch.
Die haben also direkt gemessen, wieviel Glaspartikel gibt es da.
Wer war denn das, Peter Ramsauer war der Verkehrsminister damals.
Das muss ich nicht weiter kommentieren.
Nein, ich auch nicht.
Jetzt kommen sozusagen mehrere Sachen zusammen, wo ist der Vulkan, je nachdem wie dann eben der Zugang zur Stratosphäre ist
und natürlich auch das Wetter sozusagen und das kann alles dazu führen.
Aber im Prinzip gibt es diese „Asche“, also diesen kleinen Glaspartikel, eigentlich immer.
Das war ja auch in La Palma ein Problem, die Leute mussten sich dann mit Mundschutz auch absichern,
weil das einzuatmen dann auch zu Lungenschäden führen kann etc..
Staublunge.
Jetzt gab es ja auch vor kurzem den starken Vulkanausbruch in Tonga.
Und das ist ja insofern was anderes gewesen, als dass hier der Ausbruch unter dem Meeresspiegel stattgefunden hat.
War ein extrem starker Ausbruch, der ja dann vor allem diesen Tsunami ausgelöst hat.
Inwiefern unterscheiden sich dann sozusagen die Auswirkungen von solchen unterirdischen Ausbrüchen?
Was sind da, abgesehen jetzt von dem Tsunami, den ich schon genannt habe,
noch die Aspekte, auf die man schauen muss?
Ja, ein Kollege, der mal ein Jahr bei mir als Postdoc war, ich glaube, 1990/91,
der ist da Professor in Neuseeland und der kennt den Vulkan.
Ich habe dem gleich eine Email geschickt, direkt nachdem ich davon gehört habe.
Und der hat die Anfangssituation geschildert, das war ein untermeerischer Vulkan,
der, glaube ich, insgesamt, ich weiß nicht, ich habe die Zahlen vergessen, 3.000 Meter hoch war
oder irgendwie, jedenfalls ein sehr sehr großer Vulkan.
Und der hatte in vorigen Ausbrüchen, die paar Jahre oder Jahrzehnte zurück waren,
so eine kleine Insel geschaffen.
Aber der eigentliche Top, der eigentliche /unverständlich/ war noch unter dem Wasser,
unter der Meeresoberfläche, aber nicht sehr tief.
Und weil das so flach war das Wasser, konnte der Druck des Magmas sich auswirken
und zu dieser großen Eruption führen.
Jetzt kommen wir wieder auf was, worüber wir zu Anfang gesprochen haben,
die Wechselwirkung zwischen Magma und der Umgebung.
Und Wasser.
Und insbesondere Wasser.
Und das war wohl der entscheidende Faktor.
Das Magma war, wenn ich mich recht erinnere, war wohl eine, wie wir sagen, ein höherdifferenziertes,
also ein gasreiches Magma und zusammen mit der Wechselwirkung mit dem Meerwasser,
das waren wohl die entscheidenden Faktoren für diese gigantische Eruption,
die ja hier in Deutschland auch mit allen möglichen Instrumenten gemessen wurde.
Ja, sogar mit so ganz normalen Wetterstationen konnte man es messen.
Die Bodenneigung wurde gemessen, der Luftdruck und so weiter an vielen Stationen hier in Deutschland.
Ja, eine unfassbare Druckwelle, die ja auch nicht nur von Tonga hier hergekommen ist,
ich glaube, es kreuzte sich über Algerien war, glaube ich, so der genau gegenüberliegende Ort,
an dem alles zusammengekommen ist, aber dann ist die Druckwelle auch noch wieder weitergelaufen
und es gab ja auch verschiedene Satellitenfotos, wo diese Druckwelle richtig zu sehen war.
Ja.
Also so eine extreme Kraft, die sich dann dort ausgebreitet hat.
Das war auch noch sehr dramatisch.
Also ich denke, um mehr drüber sagen zu können, muss man und muss ich natürlich abwarten,
ob der Kollege, der war natürlich dann …
er hat mir zwar gleich geschrieben, zurückgeantwortet eine Email
und der wird das weiter verfolgt haben.
Und die Leute, die dann vor Ort sind, die haben meistens keine, die müssen einfach arbeiten.
Klar.
Aber es gab ja noch einen zweiten Aspekt in Tonga, und zwar so einen kurzen Moment der Hoffnung.
Es gab ja auch eine extreme Rauchwolke oder Schwefelgasentladung mit diesem Ausbruch, die sehr hoch stieg.
Und das war so bisschen die „Hoffnung“, dass die so hoch steigen würde in solche Gebiete,
dass sie sich dort länger halten könnte, weil das dann potenziell dem Klimawandel entgegenwirken könnte,
weil wir ja dann durch verschiedene große Vulkanausbrüche solche Effekte auf der Erde ja auch schon gehabt haben und gesehen haben.
Was ist das für ein Prozess, der an der Stelle sich hätte entfalten können, wenn das jetzt hier in Tonga auch, glaube ich, so nicht der Fall war?
Bei diesen Klimabeeinflussungen von Vulkaneruptionen braucht man zweierlei.
Erstens ein Magma, was viel Schwefel enthält, Tambora 1815 ist so ein Fall,
Laacher See ist ein anderer Fall, Pinatubo hatte nicht so viel Schwefel.
Und das muss auch in der Schmelze noch sein, nicht nur in schwefelhaltigen Mineralen,
so wie der blaue Halbedelstein im Laacher See Haüyn.
Also es muss Schwefel enthalten und es muss eine hochenergetische Eruption sein,
eine, wie wir sagen, Eruptionssäule, die, wie ich vorhin sagte, angetrieben wird von der Ausdehnung der magmatischen Gase
plus der aufgeheizten und eingesaugten Luft, das ist eine Kombination von beiden.
Und wenn die Eruption sehr viel Energie hat, sehr viel Magma ausgebrochen ist
und die Eruptionssäule dann bis in die Stratosphäre reicht, also das ist ganz entscheidend.
Denn wenn Sie in der Troposphäre bleibt, dann wird es schnell rausgewaschen,
aber in der Stratosphäre, die ist trocken und da können sich dann H2SO4 Aerosole bilden.
Also kleine Teilchen aus H2O und SO2, Schwefel kann in verschiedener Form an den Vulkanen aussteigen,
am Boden meistens H2S, das ist reduziert, aber dann auch SO2, das ist das oxidierte
und das sind die Erkenntnisse, die man gewonnen hat nach der Eruption eines vergleichsweise kleinen Vulkans,
ein ehemaliger deutscher Banker würde die Peanut, das sind Peanutvulkane, wahrscheinlich nennen.
Aber im Süden von Mexiko, und zwar im Jahr 1982 und da hat man zum ersten Mal die Eruptionswolken,
die dann in der Stratosphäre zirkulierten um die Erde, von drei verschiedenen Instrumenten gemessen.
Einmal einem alten Spionageflugzeug, das berühmt wurde, dass ein amerikanischer Spion mal über Sibirien abgeschossen wurde,
U2 hieß das, glaube ich.
Und dann an einem anderen Messflugzeug mit Möglichkeiten, diese sogenannten Aschenpartikel einzusammeln
und dann hatte man einen Satelliten mit einem Spectrometer, der konnte Schwefel messen.
Also das waren die Vorbedingungen.
El Chichón war das der Vulkan.
El Chichón ja.
Und das Magma war also relativ schwefelreich und die Eruptionssäule ging bis in die Stratosphäre
und dann hat man das verfolgt über den Globus, wie die gewandet ist, diese Aerosolwolke
und das war so der Beginn eines der zentralen Wechsel im Paradigma.
bis dahin hat man geglaubt, seit Krakatau, das war im August 1883 und vorher schon
und immer danach auch, und auch jetzt noch, selbst Geologen hört man das sagen,
dass es die Aschenpartikel sind, die das Klima beeinflussen, die haben aber nichts damit zu tun.
Denn die Aschenpartikel, also die Glasstückchen, die Mineralstückchen und manchmal Nebengestein
die fallen nach ein paar Tagen wieder auf die Erde zurück.
Aber wenn sich diese Aerosolpartikel bilden, die sind so ganz klein, dann können sie mehrere Jahre um den Globus wandern,
bis sie zusammenpappen und dann größer Partikel bilden, die können dann aussedimentiert werden.
Also man braucht einen schwefelreichen Vulkan, man braucht eine sogenannte plinianische Eruptionssäule, die sehr hoch geht,
die bis in die Stratosphäre geht und dann die sind so zwischen 23 und 30 oder 40 Kilometern kann diese Aerosolschicht zirkulieren
ein paar Jahre lang.
Beim Pinatubo gibt es schöne Aufnahmen, das war ja schon Satellitenzeitalter,
das war 91, wenn ich mich recht erinnere, war Pinatubo und dann kann man sehen,
wie lange diese Aerosole aus verschiedenen Bildern von einzelnen Satelliten,
die waren, glaube ich, zwei, drei Jahre lang zu sehen.
So und dann kommt die Frage, wie wirkt sich die reduzierte Sonneneinstrahlung,
das ist ja im Prinzip auf die Erde aus?
Und da gibt es verschiedene Sachen, die man bedenken muss.
Die Pinatubo-Eruption, da gibt es hunderte von wissenschaftliche Veröffentlichungen drüber,
da in dem Sommer war ich gerade ein Jahr in Kiel, da hat es hier viel geregnet im Sommer,
ich glaube, das war Mitte Juni die Eruption, und dann hatten wir hier im Fernsehen eine Livesendung,
und die haben zwei Meteorologen eingeladen, einen Bauern, der an seinen Hühnern sieht,
wie sich das Klima entwickelt und mich als Vulkanologen.
Und das war sehr spannend.
Der eine Meteorologe, der war so älter, so meine Generation, der hat gesagt,
im nächsten Jahr wird es kalt.
Der andere, der arbeitete am Max-Planck-Institut, der war jünger, wir haben danach paar Jahre zusammengearbeitet,
der sagte, nein, es wird wärmer, aber im nächsten Jahr wird es kühler im östlichen Mittelmeer und so weiter.
In der modernen Meteorologie wird ja viel mit Computermodellen gerechnet.
Und Hamburg und Princeton sind so die Führenden.
Der eine hat ja gerade einen Nobelpreis gekriegt, der eine Mathematiker, der Hasselmann.
Das ist also das Institut und die machen Modelle.
Und während der Fernsehsendung hat der gesagt, dieser Kollege Graf, der später nach Cambridge ging,
es wird demnächst ein Kältespot sein über Grönland und dann hat er gesagt,
die siebenjährige Trockenheit in Kalifornien wird enden, die werden Wasser haben,
im östlichen Mittelmeer, weil die kalten Luftmassen kommen so über den Ural,
da wird es kälter werden und im Meer bleiben diese Klimabeeinflussungen immer länger,
weil das Wasser ist träge.
So, es ist alles eingetroffen.
Ich war mit Studenten im nächsten Sommer in Zypern, um da den Aufbau der Kruste zu studieren
und Mount Olympus ist da der höchste Teil, und da war im Mai ein halber Meter Schnee, das war ganz ungewöhnlich.
Also diese Wanderung der kalten Luftmassen über Nordural bis dahin ist alles eingetreten.
Und das fand ich sehr beeindruckend für die Präzision,
mit der man heute so Auswirkungen von Vulkaneruptionen auf das Klima berechnen kann.
Wie wahrscheinlich ist es denn, dass wir noch einen Vulkanausbruch bekommen,
der genau diese Kriterien erfüllt?
Ich meine, da muss ja einiges zusammenkommen, da muss eine extreme Intensität sein,
da muss irgendwie der richtige Schwefelanteil dabei sein, so an der richtigen Stelle auf der Erde.
Also eine Gruppe von Physikern in Harvard, die will ja darauf nicht warten.
Und die haben ja schon seit, weiß ich nicht, sechs Jahren Modelle erarbeitet,
wie man künstlich Schwefel in die Stratosphäre bringt, um diese Aerosole zu erzeugen.
Ist natürlich eine zweischneidige Sache, wie weit die sind weiß ich nicht,
ich bin damit nicht vertraut, mit dem Fortschritt der Arbeiten.
Aber da arbeiten schon einige Leute dran, die die jetzt wissen von El Chichón,
dass es das Schwefel ist und jetzt wollen sie, jetzt überlegen sie, wie kann man Schwefel in die Stratosphäre bringen.
Okay, da ist ja ein bisschen geschummelt.
Aber ich meine, wie wahrscheinlich ist es, dass so ein Vulkanereignis zusammenkommt,
wenn man jetzt so die Häufigkeit nimmt und wie oft ein Vulkan solche Kriterien wirklich erfüllt,
das scheint mir ja dann doch eher selten zu sein.
Da braucht auch ein Vulkanologe eine Glaskugel.
Haben Sie keine?
Nein, ich habe zwar ein paar Kugeln hier, aber keine Glaskugel.
Ich dachte jetzt nur so auf Basis von Wahrscheinlichkeiten.
Also es lohnt sich nicht, darauf zu warten, so höre ich das mal raus.
Nein, das sind dann hunderte von Jahren, die man gucken muss.
Also Tambora war 1815, Krakatau war nicht sehr schwefelreich, 83.
Der hat zwar viele Partikel produziert, Santorin war auch nicht, da fragen mich manchmal Archäologen mit Klimabeeinflussung durch Santorin,
ich sage, der Schwefelgehalt beim Santorin-Magma im Mittelmeer der war nicht sehr hoch.
Und auch wo wir dran gearbeitet haben, /unverständlich/ in Nordkorea, Grenze Nordkorea China,
hat auch nicht so viel Schwefel gebracht.
Also wir haben dann, unser Ergebnis von unserer Arbeit, eine Doktorarbeit,
es war wohl kein Schwefelinput in die Stratosphäre vergleichbar mit Tambora 1815.
Also wenn Sie ein Paläorheinländer vor 700.000 Jahren gefragt hätten, wann bricht da ein großer Vulkan aus,
dann hätte er das auch nicht wissen müssen.
Okay, ich habe auch nur ein bisschen gescherzt.
Aber ich kann noch mal so zusammenfassen, wir haben den Vulkanen eigentlich alles zu verdanken so,
aber retten werden sie uns jetzt wahrscheinlich nicht mehr, da müssen wir uns schon was anderes einfallen lassen,
um irgendwie die Klimakatastrophe in den Griff zu kriegen.
Ja, das ist eine gute Summary, also Klimakatastrophe und Vulkane und was die Physiker da in Harvard machen,
ist eine sehr zwiespältige Geschichte.
Am Ende müssen wir uns doch einfach nur mal am Riemen reißen.
Kommen wir nicht drumherum.
Ja, Herr Schmincke, ich sage, vielen Dank für die Ausführungen.
Das war ein interessanter Ritt durch die Welt der Vulkane und ich werde mal zusehen,
dass ich, wenn das nächste mal wieder eine Meldung ist, dass irgendwo was ausgebrochen ist
und es ist nicht gleich auf der anderen Seite des Planeten, dann muss ich da mal ein bisschen näher ran,
weil das war dann schon eine ganz interessante Erfahrung, die ich da jetzt habe einsammeln können.
Ich wünsche Ihnen noch alles Gute für Ihre weitere Forschung, weil Sie scheinen ja keine Ruhe zu geben.
So mit irgendwann mal aufhören und so weiter, das scheint bei Ihnen ja überhaupt gar kein Thema zu sein.
Nein, wenn es wärmer wird, Sie können es da sehen, die beiden Seiten, ich baue fast alle Salate hier an
und die Mohrrüben halten den ganzen Winter, die ich hier anbaue,
jetzt die letzten Tage war es abends immer sehr kalt, ich habe zwar vorher den Kachelofen angemacht,
aber ich glaube, jetzt wird es etwas wärmer und im Sommer, ich bin ein Gärtner hier.
Dann wenden Sie sich auch anderen Themen zu.
Nur im Winter ist es, weil ich keine Ananas und Bananen anbaue, ist es schwierig.
Da muss dann doch noch bisschen geforscht werden.
Ja.
Okay.
Brauchen wir ein paar Vulkane, die es wärmer machen.
So hat so jeder sein eigenes Lagerfeuer.
Ich sage noch mal vielen Dank.
Bitte schön.
Und klar, an alle, die zugehört haben, natürlich auch vielen Dank fürs Zuhören,
bald geht es wieder weiter, bis dahin sage ich, tschüss und bis bald.